Try it in there. Yeah. This one is from a Goggins.
David Goggins gave me this one. That's his coin. Yeah. He's got his own coins.
So was kind of Dan Crenshaw coin, bro. I do. This is kind of a big coin.
It's a fat one. It's not one you can really carry in your pocket now,
so it stays on the desk. He's really trying to outdo everybody else's.
That's coined David Goggins
the uncommon amongst uncommon men. Even with your fucking coins,
Jesus let go. It's not going to be that big. I'm still working on it.
Are you going to get a coin for real? We are. Yeah.
We're way behind the power curve on this. We need one. It's all about, you know,
you gotta get the right symbology in there. You got the right amount of Texas,
the right amount of seal, the right amount of Congress.
You get a pack that in into the right symbology. So test different ingredients.
Try it over and over again. Yeah, till you get the bacon, right, basically.
Yeah. Well thanks for being here man. I appreciate it. I'm glad to be here.
This is pretty cool. You a Rose to prominence through a joke.
Isn't that strange? [inaudible] form of a joke. Yeah. Saturday night live. Yeah.
That was a weird moment. And I was like, Whoa. It was,
you handled it really well though. Well thank you. Um, when that happened,
it was a Saturday night, obviously Saturday night live. And uh,
we heard about it the next morning. I got a lot of texts and everybody's like,
Oh, Hey man, you made it. It's been a bunch of seals too.
So the seal community is not prone to, you know,
this righteous indignation kind of reaction there. They're more likely there.
They were more likely in private to just double down and make fun of me more.
Right. Which I love about them. Um, but here's what they would say,
only were allowed to make fun of you and not, not this guy. Um,
so that's how we found out about it. We watched it and we were,
we were right in the middle of the campaign.
The election was about two days away. So you're,
you're struggling just to do all your last minute things to get the vote out.
And so this was, it was,
it did not Dawn upon me how big of a deal this was going to be at the time.
It felt more like an annoyance. It felt more like, okay, I've got to,
I've got to come up with a statement. I'm seeing people really upset about this,
but I'm not going to lie to them and tell them that I'm emotionally upset.
Like I'm emotionally triggered by this.
That would be a false reaction on my part. Um,
so we crafted, I think the, the right statement,
which was listed like it's offensive.
It doesn't mean I'm offended and you don't have to be,
if you don't have to choose to be offended here. And as just a general rule,
we should try hard not to offend people and try or not to be offended. Okay.
There, that's it. And I'm going to demand some apology, uh, and, and,
and kind of stand on my high horse and play this,
played this aggrieved victim role, which is,
which is the expected role to play these days. We don't want to do that. Well,
good for you. Good for you for not doing so refreshing. Yeah.
But the joke was kind of funny. I mean, I have to admit and said, he's like,
you look like a bad guy on a porno film. That not the offensive part.
What was the offensive part? Yeah,
that part was funny that it drew a lot of questions.
He called me a Hitman in a porno.
And so the obvious question is what kind of porno is this? I mean, that, right.
That's the [inaudible] that's the,
that's the next thing that goes through your head has a hit man. Right, right.
And like what's the role of that? I mean there's just,
your mind goes to all sorts of directions that that part wasn't defensive part
was he lost his eye in the war or whatever. That's what set people off.
That's what set people, yeah. Yeah. And you know,
after having gone on the show and seeing how they do things and how carefully
scripted it actually is, it's, it's, it's,
it's unclear to me and it always will be and nobody will ever come out with the
actual truth on this, on, on how that mistake got made. I think.
I think probably, uh, Pete, Dave,
if I'm just giving him total benefit of the doubt and,
and also have after having met him and, and just, you know,
having a general rule that we should try to give some people some space and
assume that they're not the evil people that we might assume they are. Um,
he probably just kind of looked at the line and didn't feel like finishing it
and just set out whatever and it just in, in that,
but that caught in that and that created this, you know,
what would actually was a pretty offensive comment. Um, but uh, you know,
did he mean it? Well, we'll never really know.
Now I'll back up and say the whole premise of that joke was ill intentioned.
I mean they said as much, right? They, they said, look at these gross people.
We don't like them and just to appear somewhat fair.
We'll make fun of one Democrat. I mean they did. They did say that. So they,
you know, they're there.
This was the thrust of the entire skit was obviously not willing tension,
but I'm not sure he meant to be as deeply insulting as it. Yeah.
You got to say the same thing. You're an American hero,
but you look like a Hitman and a porno film. Yeah, it have been funny. Yeah,
and it would've been okay. Yeah, it's the whatever. It's that part,
but he's no Joe Rogan. He was just trying to be funny man. That's all it was.
You know, people look so deeply into why comics do things,
but the majority of the reason why they say offensive shit is because they think
it's gonna work. That's why they find a thing.
It's not like they Harbor some deep resentment or anger towards any protected
class or anything like that.
This is like what people who are non comics look into it guarantee 100% like
this is going to work. That's all it is. This is going to get a laugh.
That's all it is. 100%.
And then there's other things you talk about that are important to you that
you're trying to figure out how to make funny. But for the most part,
especially on something like Saturday night live where they're all kind of
competing to be funny together. I mean that's a very weird show. It is.
And it was cool being behind the scenes and watching how it all takes place. Um,
you know, they, they come up with these wacky ideas. They, they test them out,
the writers go try it out. They, they see how it goes. They change some things.
They'll do it in front of an audience.
They'll see how the audience reacts and they'll go with that. Um, it's,
it was fun. It was fun to be a part of, it was fun to actually get,
have my input on. What was great
about it though is that you came back after that and he apologized to you and
you accepted graciously. But it also got, I mean,
it was great for you because it got people to know who you are and then I
started paying attention to you after that.
I started watching some interviews and it some speeches and different things and
I've found you to be a very reasonable right wing guy,
which I think we need way more of in this world. You know, it's like,
and this polarization of left versus right. It's just seems,
it's so toxic right now that when you can find people that are reasonable and
intelligent and think along logical lines that you could easily follow and go,
Oh, okay, maybe I agree or disagree with this guy,
but I see where he's coming from.
Yet what you're getting at is a problem in politics is as politicians and
political leaders, I think, fuck,
I forgot to explain why we believe what we believe. And that's pretty important.
Um, you know, we'll,
I think too often talking points are relied upon and it's not that those talking
points are false necessarily,
but they're not persuasive because you haven't gone a couple layers deep.
Again, I think you talk about this a lot. Why are podcasts so popular?
They're popular because people want to hear a little bit more information.
They want to get a deeper understanding of why you think, what you think.
People are ready to hear that they're ready for some nuance. Um,
that being said, being in politics, you wouldn't think,
you wouldn't think that we're getting any closer to nuanced conversations and
political conversations on podcasts or opening up a whole new door where you
understand people like Tulsi Gabbert or Andrew Yang or Bernie Sanders,
or the people that have had a, I've had on this podcast,
one of the things that I've talked to people about this and I didn't know that
Bernie was like a normal person.
You hear him talk and you know it's always in these very quick sound bites on
television. Now he's always yelling about wealth or race or something. He goes,
it looks like a mad man. Yeah,
but then you sit down and talk to him for in a long form conversation,
you let him expand on his thoughts. You go, Oh, he's a reasonable guy.
He just has this, these are his principles. His,
those are his ideas and he's not a cartoon. Yeah. I mean, on a personal level,
most people in Congress are not exactly who you think they are.
They are just people. They make jokes and we, of course, we,
we make small talk in the elevator, you know, these, these things happen. Um,
Bernie in particular I've used in the Senate side.
I don't really interact with him at all. Uh, Tulsa Gabbert I do.
You mentioned her. Um, you know, we, we, we do, we,
we do have good conversations, uh, that, that does happen.
We disagree vigorously on, on lots of things. What do you guys disagree on? Uh,
Tulsa in particular? Sure. Uh, well, most things I would say, uh,
one thing she's quite outspoken about is, um,
is our involvement overseas. Uh, she's, she would generally say she's,
she's much more of an isolationist than I am.
What I remind people when we're talking about that particular subject, why,
why do we keep troops in Syria? Why do we keep troops in Iraq?
Why do we keep troops in Afghanistan? Isn't the war over?
Um, why don't we bring the boys back home? And the,
the answer is this is not a conventional war.
This is not something where you sign a peace treaty with a uniformed, uh, army.
It is, it is a different, it's a different situation.
We send guys like me over there so that they don't come here.
We send guys like me over there so that we keep pressure on them and prevent
them for him in the operational space and timing to commit another nine 11.
You have to understand that these people over there wake up every single day
trying to plan another nine 11 is, it is, it is what they do. And uh,
we've already seen an increase in ISIS activity just from the drawdown that we
already did have in Syria. So, you know, that's a,
that's a fair disagreement again, but she's a really cool person and I want to,
I brought up Tulsi just specifically because we do talk and, and I, and I,
and I, and I just like her as a person. We just disagree on things.
But there's a respect there to play devil's advocate.
Some would say that the reason why they want to plat plot and other nine 11 is
because we're over there. Yeah, I disagree with that. So let's,
let's look at the [inaudible] in London. Um, example.
What exactly did we do to this guy? You know, we helped him, right? Yeah,
exactly. So in the nice Soviets with the Mujahideen exactly in the, he,
he was a majority and fighter. We helped them fight the Soviets.
We protected Saudi Arabia from invasion from Saddam Hussein.
That's his Homeland. And yet he hated us. And when we left,
we'd never occupied Saudi Arabia.
We left when they asked us to leave after we defended them and prevented another
invasion from Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait.
What is it we did to make this guy so mad?
And the answer is we didn't do anything. Objective. Lee speaking,
he hates us because of our Western ideology. He hates us because he hates us.
And, and it's hard for us to understand because it's not logical,
but it is the truth. And um, it's,
it's so [inaudible] and it's the prime example of why we this, this,
this is a longterm fight. And it's, um, it's not likely to go away anytime soon.
And at the last thing I would say the world is a very small place. We can,
when we pretend that we had to ignore things going on in the middle East,
we can pretend that they won't come here.
But the reality is that's a 12 hour flight and,
and the speed of information travels even faster. You know,
when we were seeing a lot of attacks in the U S and in Europe when ISIS was at
its peak as its at its peak strength,
that was because they were able to radicalize online notice that they've stopped
having that power and it's because we actually took the fight to them.
We'll there,
there's certainly are some conflicts between their ideology and Western
ideology, but why on Western values,
but why is it that they're dedicating their entire life to try and take down
America? Well, they, I mean there's, this is always the question.
It is a question that it's, it's, you know,
you would almost have to ask them exactly why. Right.
But I mean at its core we are infidels at at its core there is, they are there,
they are taking an extreme view of Islamic fundamentalism and believing that we
are infidels that must
be destroyed. I mean that's at its core, uh, there,
there it's a less political reasons and a little bit more emotional reasoning.
There has to be some,
some part of it because of our policies and some part of it because of our
actions. And I don't know,
I'm not so sure that we should always assume that it's our fault.
And I think that's a common, that's a common theme, uh,
in politics these days where anything bad happening must be America's fault.
It must be decisions we made. I mean, maybe,
but let's objectively make the case if that, if that's, if that's true.
I think there's an automatic assumption and I, it's not self evident to me,
but if we're in,
what are we in a hundred and how many countries do we have basis and what's the
number? Do you know? That's a lot. It might, it's definitely over a hundred.
Yeah.
And if you were one of the people that is in one of those countries and you had
to deal with that and you saw like the drone attacks in Yemen that have killed
people and wedding parties and the kind of shit that we hope never happens again
but has happened in the past,
you can kind of understand why there would be a hatred against the number one
superpower in the world. Will opinions in these countries are not,
are not homogenous, right? They're there, they're vastly diverse.
There's a,
there's millions of people in Yemen probably begging for us to come there.
Same with Iraq. Iraqis did not want us leaving. They knew this would go badly.
But again, not all Iraqi's. Right. So the ones who understood, right?
I mean it just depends on who you talk to a, so again, it's, it's,
it's everything is more complex than a simple than a simple black and white
scenario where America's bad or good. It's just,
it's always more complex than that.
So you feel like if we did pull out of all these countries,
particularly pull out of the middle East,
Afghanistan and all the basis that we have over there,
that it would be a very similar to like what's going on in Iraq,
what happened in Libya? There's a power vacuum.
The vacuum gets filled by bad guys. It'll a hundred percent happen that way. Um,
you know, and it's, I, there's not a doubt in my mind,
there's no doubt in any experts minds who's looking at this.
I would also say when we're, we have a base somewhere that is, that is at the,
that is, that is at the discretion of, of that, uh, local government.
There's, there's no cases here except in the case of Syria, uh, where, you know,
their local government, Bashar Al Assad doesn't want us there.
That's the only case I, that I can think of and that,
that we don't have an agreement,
a status of forces agreement with the government there. So I don't,
I don't think it's quite right to paint it as some kind of imperialistic
occupation. That's just, that's just not how we, how we do things.
And you're right over there. Yeah.
I'm just making sure this side sound is all good for you before anything
actually did happen. Now, um,
do you think this is a,
a political ploy that this is a popular thing to say because so many people that
have, uh, you know, a cursory understanding of foreign policy,
they look at our military bases overseas and they say, Hey,
let's bring those people back. Let's end these Wars.
Let's stop spending this money. But you're not the only one that's told me this.
And particularly not the only one that's told me this that's has a military
background.
I'm saying it's virtually impossible to prevent any of this stuff without having
basis over there. That's 100% right. Yeah. I mean you, you need,
you need that relationship with the host nation of course,
that you want to partner with. And that's generally what we do,
especially in the special operations community.
When we're in a hundred plus countries, we're there to partner with them.
We're not there doing our own thing.
We're there partnering and training and equipping and enhancing their
capabilities so that that's part of what we're doing.
And the other part is just knowledge. We want to know what's happening.
We don't know what's happening. Why do, why do we have embassies everywhere?
Part of that is just relationships and knowledge and understanding of what's
going on because we can't look at it from afar and actually get it. It's just,
it doesn't work that way. So, and, and, and again, I, and I'm not,
I think it is reactionary to just assume that we have bad intentions all the
time and that everything is American's fault. I hear that constantly. Um,
mostly coming from the left, but, but,
but that isolation is sentiment certainly comes from the right as well. And, uh,
and it's a reaction.
It's a reaction to the Iraq war and some of the mistakes we made there to
reaction to Vietnam. It's never,
that's never left the American psyche in many ways. But these,
these matters are complex and they deserve complex reasoning and analysis and a
little nuanced understanding. And I,
they just think that's how we should look at it. We don't, we don't say that.
We're always right. That's, that's not what I'm saying, right.
It's no one gets really educated on it. It's not like there's a cursory,
you know, examination of this that's given to the American person.
Like when they sign up to register to vote, it's like you, you don't say, okay,
before you vote,
let's explain to you what's going on and this is why there's bases here and this
is why we do this. And yeah.
I mean not even as a real simple explanation or these things,
it's just have to go searching for it.
Or you have to rely on political pundits usually have a bias one way or the
other. It's sending an MSNBC or it's Fox news and it's, you know,
you don't know where the reality is.
You can apply and you can apply that to not just our foreign policy.
It's every issue. Yes. You know, why are things the way they are?
That's a really good question to ask. Yeah.
When we're trying to find the solutions for the things we don't like.
The first question we should ask is why are things the way they are?
And that question really gets manipulated, uh,
again on any issue. And, um, it, it is unfortunate. It, how do we fix that?
I don't know. My,
my message w when like high school kids are asking me how do they get involved
in politics? And what I tell them is it's okay not to know things first of all.
And it's okay not to choose a side just yet, right? Because there's,
there's nothing wrong with your ignorance on the why behind this issue.
There's nothing wrong with that. You're young,
you don't have the experiences yet. It's fine.
But there is something wrong with having a very strong opinion on that when you
don't actually understand it. And yes, that's,
that's what creates the animosity. That's what creates the divisiveness.
Because once you're emotionally attached to an opinion, it's,
it's not easy to remove yourself from that. Uh,
that takes a massive amount of, of, I think, humility. Um,
and which is, it was an attribute we all aspire to but maybe don't have.
Exactly. Uh,
and it's hard and so it's okay not to know and to ask questions and to just
wonder and to think may, maybe what I'm hearing isn't exactly the whole truth.
Maybe I'll look into it before I start posting on social media about how awful
that situation is or whatever. People love to know, you know,
even if they don't, they love,
they love to be the person that has the information. And
one of the things that social media has done,
this is allowed this sort of text-based debate format where people can shut
people down wrong and say this, the problem with that is this and this,
and everybody wants to be correct about things because they're married to these
ideas. If these ideas succeed, they succeed. If they,
they get a zinger off on someone and some sort of online political debate,
they walk around with like a fucking, like a peacock strut and they won.
They got one in. And for many people,
this is like the only form of competition that they participate in,
which I think is a real problem in our culture.
Human beings desire competition. It, especially men,
it is a giant. And when they shy away from it, they usually become secretly,
quietly angry. And they, they,
they Harbor Harbor resentment and bitterness and they never understand the
feeling of losing and getting better.
The feeling of failing and improving the feeling of not knowing something and
then learning something like these, these things are critical.
And to pretend that you know something when you don't,
it's a terrible way to go about your life.
Yeah, I mean that's a very good point. And the competitive aspects of things,
uh, you obviously compete a lot.
I've competed a lot in my life and I can't imagine a world where that didn't
happen.
And I can't imagine a world where I didn't have to suffer as a kid through some
losses and my soccer game. And then when my parents didn't say, well,
you deserve to win. They said, well, you lost. So, so that's what happens.
And guess what? Welcome to life. We still love you, but you fucking lost.
That's life. That's real. Should have trained harder.
It's the idea that they're doing that with these little kids. Man.
When my daughter was three, she had a soccer game where there was no winners,
no losers. Like, ah, the other team, fucking one.
I watched until the ball went in the goal. Everybody was cheering. Like,
what are we doing? We don't know what I keep in score. Yes. This is bananas.
You're gonna, you know, it's soft times than this.
This is what we're living in. So off times create soft people. Yeah,
that's right. Um, and we talked about this before. Yeah. Before the show.
I'm writing a whole book on this actually. Uh, and, uh,
it's about outrage culture. It's about becoming too soft and, and, but I,
but I try to make it a, you know, a, a productive conversation.
Each chapter will be lessons derived from my own experiences and derived from
psychology, uh, derived from ancient truths. Actually a, the, you know,
nothing
I will say in this book is going to be new. But that's kind of the point.
And that's how you know it's good.
Yeah. We need to hear those things over and over again. You know,
sometimes you forget them.
Sometimes they just need to be cemented in your psyche.
And competition doesn't mean being mean. It doesn't mean people there.
They're associating it and equating it with either violence or aggression or a
toxic masculinity.
There's all these words it kept throwing around for people feeling bad because
they lost.
But that feeling of feeling bad because you lost and thing is extremely valuable
in your life.
And I don't want to say it hardens you because it doesn't hard you emotionally,
you still are the same amount of emotional availability,
but you get if you're accustomed to it, and I always tell people,
young men get involved in martial arts,
especially jujitsu because you can do it and you're not going to get brain
damage. You get strangled a bunch,
you get your ass kicked all the time and it teaches you humiliating.
It teaches you humility and then you learn after that that you can get better.
And then eventually you become the hammer instead of being the nail. And that's,
that's something you can actually apply to your real life.
You can understand that these lessons of failure and humility and humiliation
and just getting pummeled, like all that stuff pays off. Ultimately,
if you just keep showing up, and that's analogous to life in life.
If you can just keep showing up and keep working hard,
you're going to have setbacks. You can,
but don't let them define you and you can move forward. But if you don't,
if you just liked the world's toxic and we need to Nerf everything and you know,
everyone needs a safe space while we're,
we're just gonna make a whole Island full of pussies and we're in danger of
doing that.
Yeah,
we're definitely in danger of doing it if it hasn't already happened in many
ways. And like what you're saying is intuitively true,
that hardship creates a stronger mind, right lesson. But it's,
it's not just intuitively true. This is, this is in data. This is in,
this isn't science as well. Um, and in a lot of psychological research,
you know, this is, uh, and, and we know it to be true.
What if the reason I like, actually I love the,
the subject of psychology because it kind of tells us things that we already
Intuit to be true. And, uh, and it just makes sense. And,
and this is certainly one of those and there's a lot of studies that show that
people who have suffered deep trauma, um, uh,
ended up better for it as long as they're telling themselves the right stories.
And so this, I go into this a lot, my book too,
you have to tell yourself the right story about that trauma. Uh,
you have to tell yourself that you are resilient and that you,
and that you are empowered to overcome it.
That's a very important narrative that you have to tell yourself.
If you tell yourself it just happened to you and it's not fair and everybody's
out to get you right.
I wouldn't wish that psychological state on my worst enemies, I agree.
Well maybe my worst enemy, but, but that's the point, right?
Like you would never wish that upon somebody you like. Uh, and that's,
and that's, that's, that's an important truth.
I think we have to tell ourselves,
when you were in the military,
is this something that they taught you or is it something that you learned?
True example? Uh, yeah, I think through experience.
So you know, the,
the reason buds so buds is basic underwater demolition slash seal training.
It is, it is our six month trial by fire, um,
selection process that we go to become a sales. The very first thing you do.
And uh, it's where you see all the infamous footage,
GI Jane and hell week and all that stuff. That's all.
It's all first phase in buds. And so I like how you brought up channel chain.
Yeah. Well, yeah, it is that, that yeah,
it's probably the wrong example in hindsight.
All the Navy [inaudible] cause I can't think of any other movies that show buds.
Um, now that you bring it up, I actually lone survivor,
the very first interview I think has some buttons anyway, find it on YouTube.
Uh, you know, most people know what I'm talking about, but uh,
his GI Jane is not a realistic movie.
It's one of the least realistic movies and every single aspect about the seal
teams. But the point is, is, is that there is a,
there's not just a hardening of the mind that occurs from hell week.
It's like a, it's a, it's an,
it's an increase in confidence in a pretty excessive way. Like,
if I can push my limits this far, imagine what else I can do. And, uh, in that,
and then you, and you continue to push those limits. I mean,
just even after hell week you do it, uh, when you're kind of what we would,
what I would describe as controlled drowning. And, uh, in second phase where we,
where we learned to be super calm under water, under the worst conditions,
meaning you can't breathe and you're about to pass out, uh,
and you're still going to go through procedures in a very specific way.
You have to learn that, that, that calming and then you,
and you've pushed another limit and you've pushed another limit.
So bet that by the time we do get to combat, uh,
we have already suffered so badly in training that the combat doesn't feel all
that bad and,
and we're ready to get your eye blown out of your head like I did. Uh,
you're ready for that. You understand it and it's, it's not surprising.
You don't react as, you know, in an emotional way when it does happen, uh,
because you've allowed yourself to be hard.
And then you've told yourself the right story about that.
What is the traumatic experience of it and how we can be really is,
I broke my leg the first time through. I had to do it again.
So was a just a stress fracture that turned into a fracture and it just snapped
at us while we were running with the boats on our head.
So we run with these two or 300 pound boats in our heads.
They're basically kind of boats you use and um, river rafting and,
but we run everywhere with them. Um,
some estimates maybe up to 200 miles and just how weak alone. So, uh,
it's, it's one of the reasons the older, older guys, you know,
maybe 25 and older have a lot of heart, a hard time getting a hold of those 25.
That's hilarious. Yeah. Because your, your body just breaks, you know,
early twenties are probably the prime time your muscles are developed about that
time. Uh, your bone structure can still handle the,
the just immense amount of punishment that it's taking. And uh, you know,
except for mine we call it, we know,
and then we'd make fun of each other and say, Oh,
nice weak jeans you have there. That's why you broke. So your broke in.
How much time did you need before you went back to do it again? Uh, six months.
So I was enrolled three classes, which, uh, which bone? A left tibia. Oh, okay.
Yeah. That's a big one. Yeah. Yeah, it hurt. Um, you know, it's,
that's a dangerous one to break too, that not a lot of blood flow there. Yeah.
It's amazing that you got back in there six months later. A lot of times,
I know guy broke his leg and, uh, he was,
he was fucked up for a good solid a couple of years. Yeah. And, um,
and it was a risk because we weren't sure. I, I the,
the frankly the command was getting impatient. They're like,
we're not going to let you heal anymore. Six months is it? So go for it. Um,
and uh, you know, it's, you know, it's not like a compound fracture either.
This is a crack in the bone. So maybe in any case it worked out just fine.
But, uh, it's a risky thing because I knew it broke. Right. I mean,
I felt that I rounded a corner and my adrenaline kinda took me through the rest
of that run. Then we sit down for lunch and I couldn't get back up from,
from that seat. Like it was, it was the adrenaline worn off.
There was something bad, badly wrong there. And, uh,
there's always this question that the instructors will ask, are you hurt?
Are you injured? Because there's a difference.
And if you're just hurt because everybody hears hurt. If you're just hurt,
then you're just quitting. Right. If you're injured, okay,
we might give you another chance. Isn't that interesting?
That's for the average person.
That's such an alien thought alien question. Are you hurt or are you yeah,
it is. But there's a difference in there is a difference. Yeah. Now, um,
do they have any courses where they explained to you how your mind works and how
to overcome questions and doubts that creep in your head or they just,
they're teaching you through fire. Right.
And we wouldn't want those courses, frankly. Um,
so when you see all those like online people,
what you gotta do is you gotta face your fears and understand who you are and it
say it's going to be okay. [inaudible] does that, does that drive you crazy? No,
it didn't drive me crazy. I don't mind that somebody's trying to do that.
I say that we wouldn't do it because, uh, the point is,
the point is that you're already that person.
You're a seal before you got there. Okay. We're just,
we're just making you prove it because you are already that guy. Okay.
Because you never had a choice and a is another chapter in my book,
I call it no plan B. You go through this with no plan B.
If you ever thought for a second that maybe I can make it through buds,
like maybe I'll make it through hell week. I hope I do.
You're not gonna make it right. There's a choice there. You're, you're, you're,
you're telling yourself that you actually have a choice.
I think that's with everything. Yeah, it is with everything. Cause I get it.
This is plan. It's an extreme example, but it's certainly applies to everything.
If you replied to my run for Congress,
like if I didn't plan anything after the primary on March six they just did it.
Now you could argue that that was probably not a great idea.
Maybe you should've had some kind of backup plan what worked, but, but,
but mentally it was more of a mental state than it was like a don't have a
backup plan. I'm not saying don't have contingencies in your life.
I'm just saying an only,
you know when you've actually decided to quit. Right.
Cause it's one thing to be like,
I have tried to be an artist for so long and I'm just not good at it.
And then you quit. Well,
is it really quitting or is it just facing reality that you're just not good at
being an artist? You know that. So it's, it's different.
You have to distinguish between those two things. But you know, you know,
if you quit because you actually quit, you gave up on yourself and that's,
and um, and, and nobody, nobody can really judge that for you. And I, I just,
I think that's an important lesson and that's how you make it through buds.
Cause you never had a choice. Yeah.
I don't think there's a way you can get through what I've heard described and
while having a plan B, like I hope I get through this, but if I don't, I've got,
you know, I'm gonna open this pizza place with my cousin and yeah,
I always talk about it like bandwidth.
And I would say to people like if you want to really do something,
you only have like, let's call it,
let's like pretend you have a like a certain amount of juice,
like your juice is 100 and when it's fully on, do you have a hundred?
Well if you take 30 of it and you put it towards this and another 20 and you put
it towards that,
well guess what you think you're all in but you really only 50% in because
you've got all this, 50% of your juice is on all these different things.
You gotta be 100% involved in what you're trying to do at your best.
If you're not like for fighting. That's a big one.
When I tell guys there's a lot of guys that I know that are kind of one foot in,
one foot out and I'm like get out, get out.
Cause there's a fucking animal out there.
Cause some Mike Tyson when he was 20 years old and he's going to rearrange your
liver. Don't do it.
Get out now because there's people that are all in and when you're half in,
those people that are all in you become their highlight reel. That's a good,
that's probably good advice. So that's, that's the best advice you see it,
you see guys that are just starting to think, well maybe one more fine,
like fuck, stop. Just stop now. Yeah, don't do it. That's how you get hurt.
Yeah. It's um, it's a,
it's an interesting thing because of this world where there are so many people
that are teaching lessons that are teaching, you know what you got.
But then there's real ones like Jocko, you know,
like when a guy like Jocko says something,
everybody listens because he's done it. Like this is real shit. And you know,
you see his watch every morning on his Instagram, four 30 in the morning.
So annoying. He's up. It's very annoying when you wake up. I'm not,
we're not all morning people, Jocko, he's not either,
he's not a morning person either. You'd like to sleep in,
but he gets up and he fucking gets after it.
And that guy is fuel for fucking millions of people in this country because it
was great. His books and his videos and all the time, that video. Good.
You've seen that video? I don't think I've seen a lot of them.
I'm not sure which one you're talking about.
I think about that when I run cause uh,
like it's talking about things going wrong. Good. Oh chance to get better.
You know, everything fell apart. Welcoming the group, welcoming the failure.
And like that's just when I was on his podcast a while back and I hadn't gotten
to his book yet and I was like, Jocko, I'm so sorry. Haven't read your book yet.
He's like, it's fine. It's just, it's, it's one less than you have to know.
Everything is your fault.
It's extreme ownership is like everything we learned in the teams. I'm like,
okay, yeah, I know that. Cause you taught it to me as you were, you know,
he was, he was the head of trade at when I went through and, um,
and he just crushed us like everything, the shore, every, every,
uh, every training up was, uh,
this is people on this life that are both on the crush things. Yeah.
That guy's boy, he's put here to crush things. He, uh, rolled my friend John,
my friend John Dudley, who's a, a professional archery coach and a bow Hunter,
and he wanted to learn jujitsu.
So we started taking some classes and then he rolled with Jocko and Chaco
literally broke his neck.
He broke a bone in his neck and he didn't even mean to broken him.
Broke the other guy's neck. Just to be clear, John's a bone in John's neck.
It's got something in the back of his throat that still tickles him to this day.
Or it's, none of this surprises me that Jocko broke somebody's neck.
Don't fucking roll with that gorilla. What are you crazy? The guy's five 10.
He weighs 240 pounds. Don't fucking roll with him.
He's terrifying pills for jujitsu. Built to snap things off. Yeah.
That's what he's built for. It's exactly right. But people like that,
that you know,
have real lessons because of real success and real failure in life and a real
understanding of what it takes to motivate people, what it takes to be a leader.
I think those guys are extremely valuable,
but they get watered down by so many people that are out there giving lessons
and like making a career out of being a motivational speaker when you just want
to grab them, go, what the fuck have you done? Right?
What have you done other than motivate people and with words that you've just,
you,
you like collecting words out in the field and jumbling them together and you're
like a a word harvester and you're putting them together but they're not really
coming from a real place. Yeah. And then the question is, are they even,
are they successful? And that maybe they are, but you're right.
If you're not backing it up with,
I think real experience and a real story to do to frame the argument that you're
trying to make.
And maybe the arguments the same as the other guy that you're talking about.
It doesn't really have the experience,
but if it's going to be powerful and meaningful to somebody,
I think it does have to come from a place of experience. Well,
it's one of the reasons why I, I really like politicians that have served.
I think it's so critical when you're talking about sending people overseas to
have an honest understanding of what that really means and to have been there.
So one of the reasons why I really like Tulsi,
and it's one of the reasons why I really like you, I think that is,
it is a giant factor. I mean, I don't want it to be mandatory, but God damn,
when,
when people start talking about going to war and they have no understanding
personally about what that means, it bothers me. Yeah.
And it's going to war or not going to war or not going to war. Right.
Both opinions. Because again,
with me and tells you really disagree on fundamental,
I think on a deeper level is whether our troops out there are victims or not.
And I, I do, I,
I think there's a common misunderstanding that our troops don't want to be
there, that our troops are being victimized by our bad political decisions. And
that's to me as one of those people who voluntarily goes out there,
which is by the way, everybody cause everybody volunteers to, to do it. Um,
you know, that's, that's a deeply problematic opinion cause it's just not true.
Uh, you know, the, the truth is, is that we want to be there.
We want to be serving debated her on this and had her clarify her positions. Uh,
no, no. We've, I mean we can, we talk a lot, but uh,
it'd be interesting to have you guys sit down and talk about it. Yeah. Again,
I like Tulsa. So yeah, that'd be one of these days.
That's also nice too, that you guys have these differing political philosophies,
but yet you can be friendly with each other because in today's day and age,
I mean, I don't know what the fuck happened.
Somewhere around 2016 when Trump won,
everybody went haywire and now you're either with us or against us.
You can't talk to Republicans. And if you do,
you're a bad person and you're a part of the problem and you're probably a white
nationalist. And like it's this,
it's the most divided I can remember ever this country being,
yeah, it's insane. Um,
now on Capitol Hill it's a little less like, I think behind closed doors,
people do talk to each other quite a bit.
And I think it'd be good if the American people understood that that's actually
what happens. Um, so they, we, we do debate vigorously in public and,
and some of us don't talk to each other. Just to be clear, it's not, it's not,
not every show, not everybody. Yeah. It wasn't that well,
we kind of do right on Capitol Hill. I mean, between, we kind of do, I mean,
I put so much of what I do everyday out on, on social media. Yes.
And others as other members of Congress do sometimes new thing. Right? Yeah.
And it's, it's a great way for people to get to know you.
I think there's a lot of value in that. Uh, you know,
the old political way of thinking is don't say too much because they'll,
you'll get crucified for it and stick to your talking points because there's
just, there was for a long time, there's still,
there's still this argument to be made that there's no reward for being open and
honest about things for having that nuanced conversation. And uh,
that is still true by the way. I've certainly discovered it on my own,
but just that the backlash, I think the backlash that you'll get from,
from certain groups of people is, is,
is quick and Swift and unforgiving. And this is, and this is why,
this is why now again, is it worth it for me? Yes.
I think it is because I'd still rather have that open conversation.
I'd rather sit with you for hours and actually get through this stuff.
I think that that backlash is just the vocal minority.
And I think there's a tremendous amount of people that are happy that you've
done that and support you for doing that. They're just not vocal about it.
They think you're probably right. I know for sure.
Cause when I talked to my buddies that, uh, you know, when I said, Hey,
I'm having that Dan Crenshaw and like, Oh, I fucking like that guy, man.
I'm like, do you ever post on his Twitter? No.
Do you ever post on his Instagram? No. Yup. They,
there's a lot of people like that. They just,
most people are not going to comment on a YouTube video. Most the vast majority,
most people are gonna watch it go. Oh, that was good.
All I can say, I've never commented on a single YouTube video. There you go.
I mean, I have disparaged people who comment on YouTube videos in the past,
but look, I don't have a cubicle job. People get fucking bored.
I'd probably be commenting too, but the,
the idea that just the people that are angry at you are the only ones that are
paying attention. It's all backlash. I think you just not see,
you're not reaping the positive aspect as a perspective perspective is hugely
important and you're absolutely right. Um,
but, you know, trying to, going back to the political culture,
trying to move it into this a little bit more of an open and honest nuance
discussion, uh, I think is important and we just,
I want to be part of that solution. And it's why come on a show like this?
It's why so I other politicians come on shows like this,
it is moving in that direction. And I think it's, I think it's a cool thing.
I think so too. And I think people need to understand that there's, you know,
what are the motivations behind these decisions? Like what, what's the,
what's the thought process behind these decisions?
You just don't never get that on one of those panel shows where there's two
people barking over each other,
then you've got five minutes to talk less than that. You know?
And that's why on every major bill I'll put out a video and I have to be
conscious of how deep I can go into the policy. Cause again,
people will just stop listening at a certain point. So there's, there is a,
the appetite for long form discussion isn't all that big. But two,
three minutes, five minutes. Is this on YouTube or what do you,
I put them on YouTube.
I put them on and I put them on all my social media accounts. So,
and on every big bill on every big bill that we're voting on, um,
and I just tried to explain why am I for this, why am I against this?
Here's the reasons, here's what the other side says.
Here's what I say about that. Okay.
And so just let me explain to you why I do what I do.
And it turned out people really like that. No, people love that.
And they didn't exist before. I mean,
we are the first generation that's experiencing politicians having their own
channels to express themselves.
You used to have to go to NBC or CBS or what have you to in order to,
and you had to,
you had to be prominent enough to have a conversation with someone.
Like they're only going to talk to a select number of people and the only reason
why they're going to talk to those people because they think those people would
be viable in terms of the amount of numbers of people that would tune in so they
could get a good advertising money for it. And that's really the market.
That's what it was all about. We're in this new world now, you know,
and I think it's for the better for everybody. It is. It is. I mean,
they're like everything. It's got its pros and cons. Um, what are the cons?
We'll just, uh,
social media in general I think allows a lot of the,
that that vocal minority who's mostly angry and it, and it elevates that to,
to a high extent. Um, and it makes us a little angrier at each other, I think.
And that's, that's just a downside.
Now th does that mean I want to get rid of social media? No.
What is your take on what we're seeing now with social media in terms of like
algorithms that sort of accentuate that, that, that hate
where they find the things that piss you off,
whether you like to post about immigration or abortion and whatever it is and
that's what you're gonna find in your feet,
puts that in front of you. Yeah. Um, you know, I think, uh,
my concerns with the social media companies are more of the censorship issues
that we're going to get that next. Yeah. Nothing.
That's generally what we talk about. Um, I don't,
I haven't thought a whole lot about the algorithms and how that works.
I kind of wished they would do it differently. Uh,
but they don't and I can't force them to do, do it differently,
but maybe they should recognize that it is accentuating that anger quite a bit.
And you'd have to ask yourself at a certain point, well, Y, Y, Y,
Y encourage that. It's not, it's not helpful. So yeah,
no, it isn't helpful. And it seems like it's only for profit.
The reason why they do it is because the more people click on things,
the more advertising revenue they're gonna generate. Right? The best way.
I mean, it's not a malicious idea,
it's just the algorithms have figured out what's the best way to keep people in
engaged. And that's through outrage. It's not through through cuteness. Yeah.
It is memes and it's, it's, it's frustrating. You know,
you know what tweet is going to get 50,000 plus likes. Yeah.
It's gotta be hard hitting. It's gotta be punchy. It's not going to be like, uh,
your, your, your nuanced,
thoughtful take on issue X is,
is not going to get a ton of traction. And so there's an incentive there.
And again, so we can, and it's not totally the social media company's fault.
Like we always have to look to ourselves as a culture and I think, and,
and be a little introspective and, and just ask ourselves like,
why am I rapping? Do I want to beat this way?
Do I want to be that person that reacts so angrily that did that, that,
that post comments to somebody that I would never have the guts to say to their
face, you know, do you really want to be that person?
We do have to ask ourselves as a culture about that. And, and it's this,
you know, it's,
it's a lot what I wrote about after the Saturday night live thing like let's,
we, we have to get to this point and it's a pretty low standard where we're
attacking ideas and not people and not the intent and character of people.
And a, it's a low standard frankly as far as political discourse. But it's a,
it's a good place to start. It is a good a
place to start and there is a problem with the gatekeepers of social media and
that these companies are all left with their policies and they might be right in
terms of their business practices.
And David Pacman came on here and argued that and actually makes a lot of sense
that in terms of like how they still, uh,
shuffle money overseas and avoid taxes and they do this,
a lot of right-wing business practices.
But my thought on that is it's probably just compartmentalization and you're
dealing with business people that have taken over some multibillion dollar
corporation and that this is the business aspect of it.
And then you've got your social engineering aspect of it.
And the social engineering aspect of it is, it's very problematic for me. Um,
there was an article that was written recently and one of
the guys,
he was saying something about me in that no silencing white nationalists and
keeping them off your platform is not censorship, which is the way,
the dumbest way to sort of boil down my position on censorship and ignore the
real problems of other people deciding what someone can or can't say and what is
or is not offensive. I'm one of the best examples is a woman name. Uh,
I think Morgan Murph, Megan Murphy,
Megan Murphy is her name that she's a what's called a trans exclusion exclusive
Solutionary, what's the word? Why?
Why am I an exclusionary trans, exclusionary, radical feminist of turf?
And she was in a debate with,
I don't blame you for not being able to remember that trans exclusionary but
exclusionary, that weird word.
She was in a debate with people about whether or not trans women should be able
to invade feminist women's spaces.
So a person who is biologically male,
who becomes a female later in life should be able to make decisions in feminist
debates and in getting into their sports. So she says, yes,
the sports is the big one for me, particularly fighting. She says,
but a man is never a woman. This is what she says. Okay.
So Twitter asked her to take it down. So she takes a screenshot of that.
She takes it down, takes a screenshot of it and repost it like fuck you.
Like I'm going to put it back up again. This way they banned her for life,
for life. You know who's on Twitter with no problems? OJ Simpson.
OJ Simpson murdered two people.
He fucking went to jail for armed kidnapping and he's on TV. He's on every day.
Go to the world. Hamas among other things too.
This is Megan Murphy. She says a man is not a woman. She's fucking correct.
Biologically. She's biologically correct. I mean if we wanted to,
aside socially,
culturally that we were going to accept this person as a woman is a completely
different discussion, but she's right. She's biologically correct.
Scientists would say, well here we go.
We've got some chromosomes here and we've got X and Y and this is a penis as a
vagina. This is a man, this is a woman and you know,
maybe this person identifies with being a woman,
but she's saying you're not a woman and you're banning her for life. It's,
this is crazy. This is this woke culture in its most boil down form.
It has nothing to do with white nationalism. It has nothing to do with race.
It has to do with a person that feels like their own particular protected group.
Being a feminist, being a woman, and,
and trying to like carve out rules where women are protected and she's saying,
I don't like the fact that these trans women are entering into this space and
dominating it and certain aspects. Right. And it's,
it's an example of this intersectional coalition that they've created kind of
coming, coming to terms with itself. And you know, the,
a lot of the feminist groups
aligned with us against the equality act because the equality act would have put
in into real practice this in into concrete terms,
a biological men getting into women's sports. Yes.
And so a lot among other things by the way, that that,
and a lot of feminist groups were finally coming out and saying, no,
this is not correct. Like we were a feminist group, so let's protect women,
which I fully agree with and, but, you know, on a deeper level,
it's interesting to watch that intersectional coalition just implode.
And it stems from this desire on their part to, to,
to divide everybody up into three categories of oppressed, uh,
the oppressors and then the champions of the oppressed, right.
And the woke culture is the champions. Of course,
that's how they label themselves. They were,
they labeled their intersectional coalition as the oppressed,
and then they lumped,
and then they have this whole other kind of intersectional coalition of
oppressors. And they connected all with the worst of the worst,
which is white supremacist, Nazis, Nazis. And so you're all in,
they say you're all connected with that somehow. Even,
even if you're just making a, uh,
a pretty bland statement about a biological men and women somehow that connects
to this. And this is how you see them reason their way through it. And, uh,
and what th what that does is it undercuts real basic arguments because you're
attacking the intent of that argument because you're connecting it with the
worst of the worst, right? Not we kill Nazis. That's what our country does.
We did it. And so if you're connecting all of these things you disagree with,
with that, well, you don't even have to make an argument anymore. Yes.
And the idea that you're going to somehow or another convince people that
everyone is a Nazi. Just because you say so. That's not gonna work. Yeah.
W what's going to work as people are going to just,
they're gonna go to the other side.
You're making more Republicans with this crazy talk. You're you, you. Well,
I hope so. Well that's really what's going on.
Me and my friend Chris Pratt wore a tee shirt that said, don't tread on me.
Remember that, Oh fuck man. It's a,
it's a goddamn ancient flag representing our separation from England and are
want to be able to start our own country. I mean, that's what it was. Yeah,
exactly. And it gets to a deeper culture. War one.
There's many fronts on the cultural Wars. This is a big one.
Is America based on bad things or good things?
Are we good intrinsically good or are we bad? This is,
this is a huge fissure in the cultural war right now. And you know it when,
when we, and I and I have a lot of fear that, that,
that these things are boiling up and that we're destroying the things,
the few things that hold us together, you know, as a country,
like what makes us Americans, it's not ethnicity, it's not religion,
it's not even really geographic area because our geographic area has changed
over time. It is, it is ideals,
it is ideals and those ideals are symbolized by certain things.
And it's the USS constant, the us constitution, the declaration of independence,
the pledge of allegiance to the flag, the national Anthem,
like these things matter. And I, they're very important
for a culture and, and B,
and this actually all ties back into this sort of oppressor,
oppressed kind of ideology. Because if you tell people that they're oppressed,
well then they have to look for an oppressor. And that starts small.
It starts with your parent or your boss or somebody you don't like. Okay,
it's their fault. That's why I have something bad happen to me.
It's somebody else's fault. And then it grows into groups. Okay,
now you get into identity politics. And pitting identities against each other,
then you're starting to blame institutions. Okay. And this is kind of the,
this is, this is when we talk about Bernie Sanders, this is,
he's doing this often. He's blaming institutions for our,
for our issues constantly that has met him.
That is morphed into blaming the entire country. The entire country as a,
as an American ideal is to blame. I,
I just think that's really both. I think it's historically inaccurate.
I think it's an accurate objectively, but I just think it's dangerous.
I don't think it can go anywhere good unless you just want total revolution,
which I think some people do. Um, it just, it tears us apart.
Right? And we're getting divided along. We're, we're, we're, we're,
we're allowing the pop culture to get involved in this too.
So we can't share pop culture anymore. Uh, because you know,
musicians are getting involved in politics and comedians and late night shows
and it's like, okay,
well now half the country can't even watch it because those people are just
telling them the most stupid they are.
We're losing these basic symbols that bring us together.
And then we're lots of losing the pop culture that kind of brings us together.
That should be something we can just share and then not talk politics.
But that's been removed as well. And I just, the culture war is a,
it's, it's not going a good direction.
I'm hoping that this is an adolescent stage in the development of this strange
country. That's an experiment in self government. That's what I'm thinking.
And I think this is experiment self-government,
which is a completely new thing in human history that's redefined the way the
rest of the world governs itself. I mean this, that's what America really is.
Is it perfect? Fuck no, but humans aren't perfect.
There's not a God damn human anywhere. That's perfect.
There's not a single culture anywhere that doesn't have something that's
inherently wrong with it. It's the best system for imperfect human beings.
Right. And it's, it's a system based on the, the fact, the,
the unavoidable fact that we are imperfect. Okay. And that,
and that you cannot,
you cannot constrain mankind's nature to the extent that progressives would like
to. There's,
there's a belief of from an assumption just marks this ideology and kind of
French revolution thought that you can perfect human nature,
that you can get people to be perfect eventually.
If you just give the state enough control and, and, and,
and stop certain thoughts that are bad, keep those down, keep the elevate.
These other ones you can eventually get us to where we think we should be. Uh,
I think that's utopian.
I don't see how that's ever possible and I think our U S constitutional system
understands that. You know, it, it's not, there's not,
the founders got together and just made a bunch of stuff up, right? They were,
they were, they were very well versed in history. They,
they studied it relentlessly and they took ideas from Jerusalem and Athens and
Rome and London.
They took all these best ideas and these best practices and they said,
this is probably how we should govern.
We're first going to say why government exists. Okay.
We're going to say that in the declaration of independence,
when John Thomas Jefferson wrote that the declaration of independence was wasn't
just declaring its independence,
it was also declaring why government exists and it exists to protect unalienable
rights, life, Liberty, and pursuit of happiness.
And he gets these ideas from guys like John Locke who said life,
Liberty and property are,
those are an alien noble rights and you protect rights.
You can't give them to people,
but you can protect them because they're already inherent in you their natural
rights. Okay. And then the constitution told us how to govern.
This is like how do we live together? Well, there should be checks and balances.
You should have an emphasis on local state control because the cause of the
problems are closest to the people and they should be closest to the
representatives down at that level.
I'm 51% of the population shouldn't be able to tell the other 49% what to do.
You know,
we should have an electoral college so that the biggest population centers can't
tell everybody else what to do.
There's important structures like embedded into the constitution that have,
that have allowed us to actually last. I think as long as we have,
we have the oldest political debates, the oldest document,
the world is the oldest constitution in the West.
We're the youngest one of the youngest countries,
but we're the only ones that had such a long standing constitution.
I think that's important to realize too. It's very bizarre.
They had the insight to realize that shit could go so sideways that they put all
these checks and balances together that actually can reasonably well in a
reasonably well way work today. I mean,
there's a lot of people that disagree with a lot of the aspects of it.
One person, one vote, they would like that.
They don't think that representative democracy is an important now because we
have this ability to communicate that we didn't have in the 18 hundreds.
You know,
you gotta send a fucking pony with a letter on it in order to get your word
across.
Now you can actually tweet and you could vote online if we so deem it and we've
made it legal. Um, but the electoral college,
do you feel like that, that,
and especially with like things like super delegates,
do you think that that's still the way to do things and he's still an effective
way to, yeah. Why is it because the,
the alternative is the 51% versus the 49%. And that,
that what that really boils down to is New York and, and, and,
and that Los Angeles telling everybody who the president should be, but the,
the vast majority people don't live in New York and Los Angeles.
And that's exactly the problem. 20,000,007, what is it,
9 million or something in New York.
Um, does a, but, and that's the issue, right? Cause he, you really are, you're,
you're, you're, and when people congregate in population centers,
they also tend to start to think alike. And I just think,
and on a more fundamental level,
look at the difference between Democrats and Republicans.
People always wonder what that difference is.
And there's a lot of differences of course,
but a really kind of simple heuristic to think about it is the word Democrat and
Republican. Okay. One believes in a pure democracy. One believes in a Republic.
I was saying, Democrats believe in total pure democracy, but,
but when you're saying the electoral college,
you are saying pure democracy are saying 51% of the population and can tell the
other 49% what to do. The electoral college is a,
is a check and balance against that.
That gives those States in the middle a some kind of voice that they wouldn't
have otherwise had. It makes them, why is everybody in Iowa right now?
Do you think they'd be an Iowa if, uh, if we didn't have electoral college,
could deer hunting there? Yeah, that's a good reason to go. But they're like,
but, but, but the reality is, is they would only,
they would only be campaigning in the big population centers.
They wouldn't bother going to the rural areas. Uh,
because you're gonna get the most bang for your buck.
Going to just the population area, painting,
physically campaigning and physically and also,
but also who you're accountable to is, that's the most important thing.
Who are you accountable to?
You're not going to care if you're accountable to the rural areas.
Like you should be into the middle of the country like you should be.
Because if you only care about 51% of the vote,
you're just going to go to those main population centers and you're only gonna
talk to them and you're only gonna care what they think.
And I don't think that's good. That's not a good, that's not good for democracy,
especially when we have such a wide diversity of preferences and, and, uh,
just styles of living across the country.
It's still that important to be physically in a place to campaign,
to like to physically go to Chicago, to campaign, physically go to Iowa. Yeah.
People, I think people want to see you. You know,
there's a good argument to be made that Hillary Clinton lost because she just
didn't go to Wisconsin these last days. So I think people,
people want to get to know you. People want to see you. Well,
get the good argument of Hillary too, is that she,
people didn't believe she had enough energy to go and campaign.
And I don't know. I never met her. Uh, I, I can't,
I can't tell you what the inside look at that campaign was. It's,
I just know it didn't work. Yeah. Whatever happened. Um,
when you think about what are the problems that we're facing today in terms of,
uh, of,
of voting and registering to vote in primaries and electing someone from,
you know,
your party to get to go against other parties and that this whole process is
convoluted, gigantic, involved process. Could that be simplified?
Do you think that in, in any way,
doing something online and having your ability to register to vote when you get
driver's license? Sure. You don't automatically registers you to vote. Is there,
are there ways to get more people involved? Well, you know,
there's two different philosophies here is,
are you just trying to get everybody to, to,
to quickly spend five minutes of the day and then vote? Well,
that's what you're doing for the most part in anyone. Don't you think?
A lot of people, uh, know,
if you have to actually take the time to register and go to the polls,
you're going to do at least a little bit more research on what's going on.
I think you haven't talked to my friends. Yeah. Let's see it everybody,
because I'd say it everybody, but you're [inaudible] but I think you'll,
you'll exponentially increase that number when you, when you, the the other,
the other problem is, is simple election security.
And if we're worried about the Russians hacking on our elections,
then I fail to see how putting everything online is also a good idea. Uh,
so that's, yeah, we can't, we can't be worried about both things there. Um, and,
and we are worried about Russians hacking our elections.
They've obviously tried [inaudible] tried hacking the results. I mean,
they've clearly tried to influence the way people, they did try each other.
They tried everything. Tried to do. Yeah, they did try to hack the results.
They're unsuccessful.
One of the reasons they're unsuccessful is because a lot of our election
machines are air gapped and they're all so different. Every County you go to.
I mean, so it is a mess because, because you know, we allow counties,
States and counties to be in charge of that.
But that also makes it highly resilient because it's so compartmentalized.
I mean, so from an intelligence operations perspective,
you want things to be compartmentalized in.
Our election system actually meets that and we're,
and we're working a lot with the DHS is working a lot with local authorities to
even improve upon that a lot. So they were going in the right direction.
You can't hack dangling CHADS. Remember those things?
What were those? What was it called? Those, those things that hung?
Just a hanging Chad hanging. Just hanging. It wasn't dangling.
It could have been both. That's totally different. It was like,
like they weren't exactly sure within a vote counted.
They had to like examine them. Yeah. That seems like a silly way to, I mean,
if we could do banking online, why can't we vote online?
Isn't there a way to make something where it's hacked proof? Is that possible?
I might be. It might be again. Um,
but now you're getting into a problem with, with identity. You know, again,
there's a lot of people believe you shouldn't have voting of any voter IDs.
I think that's crazy. I think we use ideas all the time.
I think you should have an ID to register so we know it's you. Right? Of course.
And then you should have an Asian just show your ID when you vote.
But what I'm saying is like what did,
wouldn't it be a better thing if more people voted or do you think that it's
better if only the people motivated to vote and participate?
Vote the way we do in it now where you have to register within a certain amount
of time and you have to show up at an actual polling place. Yeah.
Do you think that's better?
It's not self evident to me that by nature of more people voting,
things will get better. I'd like them to go vote.
I like them to put in the work and the civic and the do their civic duty and to
get educated and go vote. I would like them to do that.
But that's a separate discussion from just from,
from a moving safeguards on our elections just to get,
make it easier for them to do what is already quite easy. I mean, and this,
this is weird argument against this, like it's so hard to vote.
We're so suppressed. There's just no evidence of that and it's just a hard,
but it's not as easy as it could be if you could just register online. Yeah,
I mean I can make a million things easier, but then again,
they were moved safeguards that, that,
that that creates safe elections and elections that we can have faith in it.
That's a very important thing if [inaudible],
and I think you see this when you have this discussion with people,
they're already on edge about whether their vote really counts because you know,
some people think illegals are voting and again,
there's not a huge amount of evidence for that either. It does happen,
but it's not as an illegals vote. I mean,
in place of register and in places where there's no voter ID, you can,
you can make it a lot easier. Where's the NovaSure voter ID?
I don't believe there is in California. Is that,
am I right on that California check on that? But, um,
it's definitely not the law of the land everywhere in Texas. It is.
So Texas is a good example, I think of like very, it's very easy to vote.
I just can't imagine that people don't think it's easy to vote in Texas.
If you're senior citizen or disabled, you can mail in your ballot 30 days prior.
We have two weeks of early voting.
You can go to any election place in the County and,
and vote from 7:00 AM to 7:00 PM for two weeks straight. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I mean, and you just show your ID and you vote. I mean, this is, I,
we feel in Texas, like it's safeguard and we're not,
we're not overly worried that our vote doesn't count because it's canceled out
by some fake vote. And it's hard to, and it's hard to argue that,
that there's, um, suppression either because against so easy,
difficult where you can go on election day.
It's just a shame that we have so little faith in our ability to do things
electronically that we're worried and that we wouldn't want people to vote
online because we're worried about people hacking.
It lets that is a shame because I just feel like if you could walk,
like maybe if you were going to vote online,
you would have to watch a five minute video explaining people's positions on
things and explaining where they stand and why this makes sense and show that
and after that five minute video, then you get to vote. Yeah,
that's an interesting idea. Um, I'm not opposed to the videos of course,
forcing people to do things just generally speaking as truth is tough. Um,
but it still goes back to how do you even know it's the right person who's
sitting there at the computer. That's true too. Yeah. I mean that, that's the,
that's the difficult part with your phone. You have face ID, you know, Apple ID,
you use fingerprints with other phones. Oh, sure. I mean,
there's interesting ideas that you could,
that you could look into to make this work,
but it's a pretty massive change and it'd be a massive federal takeover of what
is, what is constitutionally a state's right to, to implement that. So,
you know, it's just, and then the question is, what are we trying to fix?
You know, when we're going to do as a massive change on to something,
what kind of improvements are we expecting and why?
And those are just good policy questions to ask.
It doesn't mean we don't have those discussions.
There's always been an issue with voter turnout. Correct? I mean, isn't it,
it's a fairly insignificant number of people that actually want to voting.
Right? Yeah. But does that, because is that, whose fault is that?
That's a good question. It's people who don't go to vote. Right?
So do you think that those people like, fuck those people,
they're just lazy and no. No. Shouldn't have a say. Not at all.
It's just that I just would encourage them to go vote. Right. Like, it's right,
but that isn't it been fairly consistent, like the,
the number of people that vote,
the percentage of people that vote across the board. Yeah. But again, it's,
it's not self, it's not self evident that that's a problem that governor,
it's up to government now to force that into, into a fix it. You know,
I, I'm not sure I see that argument's not self-evident that things would all be
better if we forced people to vote or made it so easy that they didn't have to
think about it at all and just got on their app and voted. So, yeah, it's,
it's an interesting question. Do we want to increase voter
turnout and then, yeah, sure. How do we do it? Um,
I think civic education is a more appropriate answer to that as opposed to,
as opposed to making it as easy as buying something at the grocery store.
What civic education, what form? I mean, starting with our schools,
we just don't, we don't teach a lot of civic education anymore.
And I think that's obvious from our political discourse sometimes. Uh, it's,
it's, it's not required. Like, I think it should be, you know, just,
I mean the basics. Like where does government happen?
If you're concerned about your schools,
who should you go to your Congressman or you should you go to your mayor or you
go to, right. We're going to tell people this stuff. It's like, no,
you should go to, you should,
you should get involved in your school board elections for one thing. You know,
it just as an example. Uh,
just a lot of things that I think need to be taught before we,
so I think we're trying to solve the wrong problem when we say, well,
voting's not easy enough and I'm not so sure that we're,
we're hitting at the heart of the issue when it comes to voter turnout. Hmm.
When people talk about issues in this country, there's a,
there's a giant does it giant divide with,
with one thing in particular, and that is mass shootings, uh,
mass shootings and gun control.
There's a giant divide between people that are second amendment advocates and
people that want to round up all the assault weapons and take away all the guns.
And they think that guns are the problem. When you see this
pretty disturbing increase in mass shootings in this country,
what is, what is your take on it and what do you think could be done?
Well, it's awful. Um, they're terrorist attacks and I think,
I think it's safer to call them that, uh, the, the ink weather,
depending on how you define a mass shooting. Um, now you defined,
when we look at murder statistics, we're actually at a very,
very low point in our history. I mean, you look at the early nineties,
it was vastly more murders by gun, uh,
than we have now as just statistically speaking. What's, what's that?
Because of this? They know, uh, well there was a massive war on crime,
I think in the 90s, uh, increase in police. You know,
you had some of the crime bills that went through,
which were obviously the source of a lot of debate right now in the Democrat
primary. And, uh, yeah, I just, it was just, there was a,
there was an approach to fix that. Okay. You know, tackling gang violence,
tackling all of these things. And, uh, we, we live in a much,
even though you wouldn't think so because of these kinds of theatrical, again,
they're, they're terrorist attacks. I don't know what's to call them, uh,
because, because the person doing it is trying to commit terror. Right. And, uh,
you know, for different reasons of course, but, but there are,
they at least they attach themselves to some kind of reason.
But in the end there, they're angry at something and they're, they're probably,
you know,
probably have been taking some kind of psychotropic drugs over time and they've
gotten to this point and they'll attach themselves to whatever reason they need
to do this. And it's awful. Um, so, you know, how do you fix that?
Um, we have to understand the problem. We have to diagnose it. And, um,
and then we got it.
And I think we have to be realistic about what the solutions really are and what
our ability to influence those outcomes really is. And that's the,
that's an emotional conversation for people. Uh, you know, we've,
we've been dealing with for the last few weeks, of course. I mean it's, it's,
it's front and center, um, and the debate. And so, but we got to have it.
What can be done? Yeah. Um, well the, the,
so obviously the reaction by many is to go after the tool, right?
To go after the guns. Um, I don't think that's the right approach.
It's not, it's not, again,
it's not clear that that would actually solve the problem. There's, there's two,
there's two main requirements when you're, you're looking at a,
an approach to gun control. It's like,
does it infringe on law abiding citizens rights? Number one,
what's the answer to that? And two,
is it going to actually affect the outcome that we're trying to affect?
Is it going to feel good or is it going to do good? Okay.
And I think the vast majority of proposals, um,
failed both of those standards.
They definitely infringed on law abiding citizens rights and they probably
wouldn't even solve the problem. You know, look at examples. Assault rifles.
[inaudible] well, Hey, RS. Okay. They're called assault rifles. They're really,
the reason they're in AR is because they're called ArmaLite. That's a brand. Um,
assault rifle is not a, is not a real thing. It's not a real definition.
And um, but what if you banned them? Well,
rifles are responsible for less than 3% of all gun deaths.
About 2.66% of all gun deaths. Okay. Hammers and knives, I think are, are,
are responsible for far more deaths. Um, so true. Yes.
Hammers and knives are responsible for more deaths and rifles.
Got statistics including AR back. Yeah. Yeah.
Rifles account for four, 2.6,
6% of controlling people with hammers. It's a good weapon. I guess.
I feel [inaudible] somebody has a hammer. If all you have is a hammer,
we'll put it you have, you have a gun. Yeah. You have any, well,
even if you don't have a gun, like I could stop my hammer. Yeah.
But you're a pretty good fighter. Goddamn people on air. Well that's not true.
I can take away your AR if you're [inaudible], you know,
how close do you have to pay to do that? I just got to reach it.
It's very easy to take away an AR. Yeah. Yeah.
How easy. I just, I just need to get a hand on the barrel. You should,
can I use one or two? Every classes. Yeah, I know. I mean,
I've taken those classes. That's why I know it's so easy. It,
whoever controls the barrel of any gun controls the gun.
People don't quite realize that.
They think if they're gripping it then they control the gun. That's not true.
Right. Um, and we can get leads now. Yeah,
we're getting at the way that we can demonstrate that. Yeah. Afterwards.
So I have a flame thrower. Rub that. Yeah. No rifles in here.
Is that what that I was Ilan Muslim. Sure. What that was.
Are you going to take a picture with that later? Okay. Can I,
can I actually use it though? Yeah, we can turn it on.
As long as you don't cook the ceiling. Okay. But I can cook anything else. Yeah,
you'd be the only one who's ever turned it on here. Other than anyone.
It doesn't have to be in the room, but yeah, it does though.
Picture feeling in the room. Um,
so have you thought about this? I mean if you,
if you had a magic wand and they said, Hey Dan Crenshaw,
what can you do to solve this mass gun violence?
What can you do to solve these mass shootings? Yeah, I mean you have to,
you have to target the source of them. It's just not an easy conversation.
Right. And so this let's also think about where these things started.
We're talking about the theatrical mass shootings.
There's a lot of statistics out there. They'll say we have hundreds of them,
you know, which include four or more deaths.
But these are usually gang violence. So gang violence is, it's a,
it's in a category, right?
Cause to believe there was 279 mass shooting so far this year. And some of them,
they do include gang violence. I think it's two or more.
Is that what it's deemed mass shootings? Yeah. It might be more.
Which is so fucking weird that we have a statistic. Well that doesn't count.
It's only [inaudible]. Yeah. Hey, I mean,
you gotta draw the line somewhere and you gotta, you gotta be able to, Anil,
if you're going to analyze it, you have to have to look into that. But the,
these theatrically, I think the,
the dramatize shootings at these that these guys are doing it,
it all started with Columbine and it's become this sort of copycat crime that
has occurred over time. And it like, we didn't have this before that.
And I think that's interesting. And I think it's something to take note of. Um,
and it, and it's not clear what you do about that. Um, you, you have to,
you don't have to look for signs, uh, people before they do it. And, uh,
so one bill that I'm on, which is, there's this,
I've taken a lot of fire for it because if the people are just,
I think misunderstand what it actually is, is the taps act,
which is the threat assessment, uh, prevention and safety act.
All this does is give local law enforcement the ability to apply for grants to
get training and,
and behavioral threat assessment training and data analytical tools to identify
these threats beforehand. And people that are opposed to it,
they look at it like red flag laws, right? They combine those two quite a bit.
And that's just, it's just not, it's not true. I mean, the,
the taps act doesn't actually have anything to do with guns and red flag laws,
depending on how they're implemented,
could take someone who looks like they're a Radic or who has a pension for
violence and they will say, you do not have access to guns. Right. In theory,
that would, that would be how they work and, um, they, they would fill a gap.
I think it depends on the state.
Some States have all the ability they need to see threatening behavior and then
arrest that person. Uh, but it depends on criminal law within that state.
So I theoretically red flag I would, would fill, fill that gap.
The concern with red flag laws obviously is, is there really due process?
A lot of people hear that and they're like, okay,
that means my neighbor can tell on me and they're going to cut my guns the next
morning. Well, yeah, I mean if that's how the law was written, then yeah,
you better be against that. Cause that's a terrible law. Um, and, and,
and to be fair to a lot of the people who don't like red flag laws,
they see how these are written in a lot of States and in California has one.
And, uh, and they see how those are written and they say,
this doesn't protect due process. How can we possibly before this, um,
thou, on the other hand, there hasn't been any cases where there's,
there's been some obvious abuse of that law either. So, um, you know,
I've encouraged the conversation.
I think the conversation has to happen at the state level because every state
has different criminal law and that's where criminal law happens. It's a,
it does not happen at the federal level.
The only other controversial, uh, approach that I've heard is,
uh, putting armed police or soldiers at schools,
which is like that,
that seems incredibly disturbing to me to have people look,
I'm not opposed to it,
but it's disturbing to me that you would have to have someone standing by ready
for violence. Well, we have guards everywhere. Why not our schools? Um, we just,
cause we've never had them before and it's sort of signaling that we've reached
this point of impasse where we have to do something about it and we're not doing
anything to prevent these things from happening.
What we're doing is protecting the people that are going to be there when these
things happen. Yeah.
I think inner city schools have long had police presence there. So it's not,
it's not, I don't think it's totally new. Um, the idea,
and I think we could rapidly get used to it. Uh,
there's a good argument to be made that gun free zones are,
are the first thing that are attacked too. So, I mean, you know,
it's a counter intuitive response to this, but it's, it's true.
If I'm going to commit a terrible act,
I would of course you're going to go to the place where you know,
nobody's caring. You're not going to a gun show. Right? Uh, let's,
you were just, just want to really, Leah, you're really looking for a fight. Um,
but that's, that's, there's some truth to that and it's, it's just hard.
It's so hard for people to have this conversation cause it's so emotion.
And there's a cultural Fisher here too. There's,
there's some people don't understand some people who like guns, right?
And there's a cultural divide there. Yeah.
And I just don't like people who like guns. That's,
we have to admit that's true. Well,
they'd have this idea of guns that guns bring violence and violent people want
guns. And that that's just not true.
And one of the things that people like to gloss over is how many people have
defended their life and defended the lives of their loved ones with guns in this
country every year. It happens all the time.
I've got a whole list of stats and examples that I actually read I could read to
you right now. Unfortunately,
one of the things that gets brought up during gun violence statistics and talk
about how many people die from firearms every year in this country.
They're also talking about people who defending their lives and defending the
lives of their loved ones.
People get their houses broken into all the time by armed criminals and they
shoot those people and they lay live to see another day and that person dies.
And that is the whole reason why people don't want to get rid of guns. Right.
And don't want to bring something up along those lines.
So it's far more likely in countries like great Britain that you'll get your
house broken into while you are there far more likely than in the United States.
Like by, by, by a good order of magnitude actually. So that,
that the why is that right? Because they know
that there is no gun in that house and you do that in Texas,
there's a good chance there's a gun in that house. 100% yeah.
Even the liberals like [inaudible] if you don't have a gun, right?
Like the fight takes his mind. Yeah. I don't want out a gun. So,
so that's important. An interesting point. The other,
the other good statistical analysis to do is, okay, well,
when there's high amounts of concealed carry, what does that do to crime rates?
And the co-relation is there's less crime. Okay. Now,
now it's not fair to say that's a causation. That would be,
it would be intellectually dishonest, but it's an important co-relation to know.
It's also important to note, okay, per capita,
places like Switzerland and Israel have far, far more gun ownership than we do.
People don't realize that. Is that true? Oh yeah. I wouldn't switch.
I wouldn't come in here and lie to you then. I know,
but it was done as a ritual because of the, now,
now somebody would count are again, that's another, those are,
those are government weapons issue to people yet fine.
But they still are with the people, like the people have the guns. Okay.
And their dah, dah, dah.
At a rate higher than the United States thought they were.
And there's like over there. Yeah, but they are,
that's how they stay neutral so that they have almost no crime.
Almost no cry Israel to almost no crime. Um,
except for the obvious issues that Israel has in general with the Palestinian
Israeli conflict. But as it does a criminal act,
like they have very little crimes like this is interesting.
So you combine that with what we know about concealed carry data here in the
United States. You know, how do you solve this problem?
The other thing to think about is, um, the vast majority,
over 50% of all gun crime, it happens in like 2% of all counties.
So it's highly concentrated. You can, you can.
So as we look to solve this problem, like we,
we do have to really peel back some layers here.
Like who is committing the crime? Where is it happening? Why is it happening?
Um, you know, we can attack the tools, but it's just,
it's so far from self evident that that would work. Again, going back to a ours,
they're responsible for less than 3% of gun deaths. And also,
let's say you banned him. Are you actually stopping 3% of gun deaths? No.
Cause why don't they just use another gun?
Why don't they use a different weapon? One of these,
a truck like they can use if they want to kill, they can kill the, the,
the horror that we're seeing is that they like to kill this way.
And maybe that's like, why is that? And again, I go back to Columbine,
it all started with that. And that's interesting.
We should look at that and like what is driving people to like that? Well,
I think there are a lot of people, I mean if you look at mass shootings,
a lot of these people, when you read their description,
they're very disenfranchised, a very angry.
And when you're disenfranchised and very angry, there's like an archetype,
right?
There's an image that you have in your mind of shooting all these people that
wronged you. I mean, this is a, it goes back to our victimhood conversation.
Sure. Yeah. Blame somebody else. Well,
and then the real conversation is how many of these people are on psychotropic
drugs and what are those,
what are those drugs and what are the effects those drugs have on people? Well,
when you look at the numbers, it's fucking stunning. Whether
it's antianxiety medications or SSRI or eyes or amphetamines,
or whether it's whatever they're on that alters the chemical frequency or the
camera,
the the biological structure of your brain in terms of like what chemicals are
in there, serotonin, dopamine,
these speeds that so many kids are on Adderall and various types of speed.
That stuff radically changes the way you look at the world. Yeah.
How many of those drugs contribute or are a factor in these mass killings?
I don't know if correlation equals causation,
but I do know the correlation is phenomenally high. Yeah. I mean,
I think it's on the viral, this homes, things like that. Sure. Let's,
let's start analyzing it. Bullying in cells, which is a new word,
involuntary. Celibates. Do you know about that? Huh? He didn't know about that.
I taught you about Intel's, you just did thing. Yeah.
There's whole groups online on message boards that they can't believe they can't
get laid and then they just go voluntary, involuntary signs.
They're just guys who can't get laid. Yeah, that's,
that's just a fancy word for that. You know? Let's not call them losers.
That's what makes them crazy. If there's a game,
there's winners and losers and that, uh,
high school football quarterback is banging all the cheerleaders,
that guy's a winner. It sucks. That's true.
But you know, unfair. Yeah, it is unfair. You know, I'm,
I'm hoping genetic engineering fixes all that future,
but this is what you're dealing with a lot of times as these,
these guys have got a really shitty roll the dice and that there's no other way
to describe it. They, they'd got handed a terrible hand of cards, right.
And some of 'em are pilled up and angry and abused and they have access to guns.
And then next thing you know, there's a mass shooting. Right? And then again,
going back to the victim of a conversation, they,
maybe they did wear a Delta bad hand,
but they have to tell themselves the wrong story about why that is and who's to
blame. And uh, it's,
it's that narrative just seeps within them and it creates this, I mean,
the driveway, right? I is when Bernie Sanders was on here,
there was one thing I thought I agreed with him on,
which is we have to look at the effects of these drugs and like really what they
are. I don't see anything wrong with that. I think that's true.
It's amazing how much blow back you get from that.
And it's by people that want to look at the guns. They just want to say no, no,
no. Why are you talking about psychotropic drugs? It's the guns. No,
I'm talking about the guns too. I mean,
I don't necessarily think that really angry,
volatile people that have criminal records should have guns.
I think they shouldn't. Right. So the guns are already out loud. Yes we do.
And we probably should, you know,
have some understanding of who you are before we give you a gun.
The real question is what is that understanding and how do we go about doing
that and how do we keep people from making these incredibly rigid rules? I mean,
particularly regionally, right?
If you have a States that decide to have incredibly rigid rules that Procruit
most people from having guns. Yeah.
That can be possible if they just devise their own tests and you're honest about
your perspectives on things. And that's
the fear. And it's an honest fear to have a, because, yeah. What is the limit?
You know, if you're on psychotropic drugs sheets,
you be barred from having weapons. Of course not, uh, you know,
[inaudible] and how do you,
how do you manage that and know the way we do it now again,
you have to have committed a crime of some sorts. And there's,
there's other things too. A, if you abuse medication, if you abuse, uh,
yeah, medication, then I think you're also thinking according to federal law,
like you're, you're, you're barred from, from, from owning that, you know,
that's in the system. Uh, I think dishonorable discharge from the military,
things like that. So there's,
there's already a lot of standards that actually precludes you from,
from buying a weapon. And, uh, there's a, there's a,
there would be a very vigorous debate on how you add more standards to that
dishonorable discharge keeps you from buying a weapon. That's what I've read.
We can fact check that. But that's interesting. I didn't know that one.
I thought you had to have a felony.
Hmm. Maybe, um, maybe it makes sense,
but it's, there's no answers. And this is the,
the thing that domestic abuse too I came up with from, is there something Jamie?
Yeah,
it's honorable discharge and N F a. What's an NFA firearm?
NFA refers to the national firearms act.
So that's what ban like automatic weapons based on a general court martial
conviction.
A person who was convicted of a crime that is punishable by imprisonment for
more than one year,
including dishonorable discharge is prohibited from threats from, yes. Okay.
That's what it is. So it is true.
So if you're imprisoned, not just to dispute, is that it would be, it would.
There's a lot of people dishonorably discharged the public, not, not,
not violently. You know, they're not violent.
What's disturbing talking to you? Talking to Bernie, talking to Tulsi,
talking to everybody and nobody has a solution. I mean,
we'll all the brightest minds that are thinking about this all the time.
No one has one thing that makes sense.
This gets to a very deep question about what are key,
and I think I've briefly touched on this before,
like why does government exist and what are we capable of solving and what needs
to be solved by ourselves. You know,
they're there in what is just inherent to human nature and it's evil and we hate
it and we don't want it to be there, but it is. And w and is it,
is it appropriate for us to scream to our politicians and say, save us?
And sometimes it is, sometimes we can solve and we should try. But we have to,
we have to do it with some kind of constrained vision as Thomas soul would put
it about what is possible and then let's be reasonable about what is possible.
And, and, and, and hit those two categories. I said,
are we infringing on the rights of everyone, uh, for the sake of doing this?
And second, is it going to actually solve the problem?
And those are very important questions.
And if we don't frame the debate within those, I think we're, we're, we're,
we're not doing, we're not justice to the, to
the problem itself. True. But again,
no one seems to have any logical course,
any logical, clear path. Like, this is how we are going to reduce gun violence.
This is how we're going to stop mass shootings. I mean,
other than arming all these public places, I was in Rome recently, and, uh,
when you go there, it's fucking stunning. This military vehicles,
guys with dawns just strapped, ready to rock,
just standing by all over the place. And I was like, I used to be that way.
It didn't. And I was like, wow, this is a very, uh, it's,
you know, you were trying to enjoy yourself when you're on vacation.
You're checking all, all these ancient buildings and then you're like, Oh,
look at fucking guns, military tank. I'll get that, you know? Yeah.
And it's w I wish it wasn't that way. Yeah. You know,
and uh, it, but again, like w, you know, you're right. We don't, we don't,
we haven't come up with perfect solutions.
We have some ideas that I think would mitigate these threats and we mean we've
discussed those at length. Um, but none of them seem tangible.
Everything seems like just talk,
well the taps act that I talked about I think is perfectly tangible. Again,
it's not a, they won't solve everything, but it mitigates something.
I think armed security at schools I think certainly mitigates things as far as
school safety goes. So no, I don't, I don't, I don't,
I don't think it's just talking. I think those are tangible things and I,
I think they're perfectly reasonable. Um, you know,
when people just are so reluctant to think that we need armed guards at school
and I understand it and I'm thinking about it myself more so really what it's
going to take. Cause armed guards at school, I went to high school in Bogota,
Columbia, so we had armed like a lot of armed guards at our school.
It's not foreign tomato oil.
No oil oil petroleum engineer. Yeah. So we moved to,
my life growing up was between Houston and overseas, back and forth.
That'd be very bizarre. Yeah, it was fun. I mean, I don't regret a minute of it.
That can be hard at times. I'm moving around a lot. Vanish.
They used to be better. It's not bad. I'll do an interview in Spanish,
so it's not really, it's not bad by any means, but it's not great.
So you can go into a taco and hang out. I totally hang, I speak,
I speak really well. Conversational Spanish, my Spanish,
it's harder when I'm talking complex policy issues because I didn't learn that
kind of Spanish. Right, right, right. So, but yeah, I had pretty good. Um,
one of the things that you said that you disagreed with Bernie on was lobbyists.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Well, w well,
I disagree with his notion that everything is attributable to some kind of
corporate greed and therefore lobbyists.
It's just not the source of our problems. It's,
it contributes to it in some ways. For sure. I mean, these are not,
these are selfish actors. They, they, they have a role, right?
They're advocating for a specific thing. Um,
but I think politicians like to point to them is like the, the, the book Nate,
the Nia, the boogie man.
Let's just blame them for everything that I have not,
that is not been my experience. That what hasn't,
it has not been my experience that these lobbyists of any kind of excessive
control over politicians. I just don't see that. Okay. They, you know, they,
the corporate PAC can give you $5,000. That's it. I mean this isn't, this isn't,
not in no way, shape or form can they buy anybody off? Um,
it's also very transparent form of doing things.
Is this other talking point that it's all dark money. That's just not true.
The corporate pack is a group of people who work for a corporation.
They pulled their money together. They can't use company profits. Just be clear.
This is personal money and they have limits on what they can donate to that own
pack.
And then they use that to advocate for whatever's important to that business.
And I tell people, where do you work? I'll ask you where,
what industry are you in? It'll give me whatever industry, and I'll say,
you definitely have a pack lobbying for you on Capitol Hill. All right.
And they'll, and they'll just point out bills. They'll say, listen,
this is problematic in this one. This would hurt our workers,
this would do this and put us out of business. Like don't do that. It's it. Um,
you know, and so the other, they're selfish actors don't get me wrong,
like they're, this is where they're advocating for their thing,
but that's also our democracy. Individuals can donate more now.
And so an individual cap is $2,800 to up to a campaign and then a couple like
you and your wife, we can double that. Okay. So the same as a pack.
It's basically the same. It's only $5,000 ish. Yup.
That's the maximum that is the maximum.
But there's also influence that comes with that on top of financial,
there's also influence in terms of just cronyism and people reciprocating
getting along with each other and working, you know,
establishing longterm relationships where they agree on things and they make
deals and they make deals that might not necessarily be in the best interest of
people like deals in terms of like what businesses get subsidies,
what businesses don't get subsidies, what things get negotiated,
what don't what like here's a perfect example.
Exactly the way I think we should have a less powerful government that can't be
bought off like that. You know,
you won't get married if you want government cause cronyism certainly happens.
Right? And they'll say listen, like does, you know, in, in, in who can,
who can lobby as the bigger, the bigger companies. So there's,
there's some agreement here, but it's,
I think there's this somewhat misunderstanding of what's really happening.
So yeah, a big business can,
can lobby and then the last for more regulation, so, and,
and then who does that really hurt? It hurts their smaller competitors.
So the answer is actually the who's at fault here.
It's the fact that government's trying to excessively regulate so much and it,
and it creates, it creates a situation where there's no longer competition.
Okay. And then that's a, that's a real problem now. Um, you know,
that excessive influence though, again, it's,
it's not something I've seen because there's a lot of competition for influence.
Anybody can come to your office and they all, they all disagree, right?
There's all these different interests that they actually compete with one
another and then they represent different interests. So it's not,
it's not self evident to me
that that influences is, it's certainly not bought. And, uh, and, and I,
I don't, I don't necessarily believe it's excessive either.
It's just not what I've seen. Maybe they don't,
maybe they just don't come to me. Well,
when I think it was Northwestern university did a study recently where they
were,
they showed the public support for policies and public support for,
for for bills and how low the public support is in comparison to things that get
passed and how when the public wa it was things that the public absolutely
wanted,
like across the board had something in the range of a 30% chance of getting
passed through.
Whereas there's many things that the public absolutely did not want across.
The board also had a 30% chance of getting through and they were talking about
the various influences that lead to these policies getting passed.
Now the argument is that your rep, your, you're electing representatives,
those representatives don't do you justice and pass bills and,
and enact policies that would help your community and help you.
Then you let them out of office,
but the damage gets done while they're there and the idea is that these people
would then go on from there.
Once they've established that influence and once they've helped these people get
jobs in the corporate sector,
get jobs that represent what they've done for those corporations while they were
a representative supposedly of the people.
Yeah, I think that's a,
you're gonna have to really dig into like what issue they're talking about.
What issues not supported by the public. I mean, I, that's, I,
you'd have to unpack those statistics I think to really understand what's
happening there. The, but I also,
I think that's too cynical of a way to look at politicians. I just don't,
I don't feel that way about my colleagues on the left or the right. Well,
how long have you been a Congressman? Seven months. So I just, and my, my,
like nine months in, they start coming to you may, maybe no, we meet with them.
It's just like, they just, they don't have this influence, you know,
they're not, I mean, listen, they, they present one, they, one,
they generally meet with the lobbyist that they already agree with you. Um,
and they're generally bringing up very minute things that are,
that you just wouldn't ever know about if they didn't bring that to you. Well,
there's some bills that get passed like that. Don't like, here's one,
right? Medicaid,
Medicaid spends billions of dollars on drugs for the elderly and people that
can't afford them billions of dollars. But by law,
the government's not allowed to negotiate the price of those drugs.
Okay. So the price negotiations, how did that happen? Well,
it, how did it happen? It's, well, it never, it was never a thing to begin with.
So the,
there's an argument to made that the government should be able to negotiate
prices. Right? The question is what is the price and the,
and the other thing you have to point out is there's already a strong force
against the pharmaceutical industry, which is the insurance
companies because they have an interest in making sure that price is as low as
possible.
They're fighting all the time against the pharmaceutical companies and the
healthcare industry. All of these groups are often pitted against each other.
And then as politicians, we kind of look at all of them and we say, all right,
what are your arguments? What are your arguments? Um,
w is what you're saying really makes sense.
And then we have to make those decisions based on the overall good,
but you're going to piss everybody off when you do that. Like that's,
especially with healthcare cause all of these,
a lot of these groups are pitted against each other.
So you've got insurance already pitted against pharmacy. Um,
and then it becomes a pretty good question.
Like what is government's role there? Cause I've, I've,
when I first looked at this problem, I said, yeah, yeah, just negotiate.
Well that makes sense. Um, I learned a lot more. I learned a lot more and,
and it's not because I met with any lobbyists. It has nothing to do with that.
It's because I meet with healthcare professionals and experts who know this
issue really well and economists who,
and it's very far from self evident that this would work and it's far from self
evident that would be beneficial, uh, at all and actually make a difference.
You know, when we,
when we look at the differences in healthcare spending between us and other
countries, uh, the drug prices actually have very little to do with them.
They're able to negotiate those, but they also get,
they also get last choice for medicine. Okay.
When you look at great Britain and Canada,
that they're not getting the premiere new drugs like we have in the United
States. Um,
we get screwed as Americans because the patent laws are not enforced in these
other countries. So our pharmacy, our pharmaceutical companies, um,
they immediately get ripped off in other countries and that, that's a problem.
You know, how do we fit that?
So that should be something we think get ripped off in that they've done the
research to create these drugs and these other companies in the other countries
to just copy these, draw and make generics.
Yet because they have socialized medicine and their obligation is to provide
medicine to the people. So their obligations to,
they don't care about these copyrights,
they just care about getting medicine to the people. Now,
some people would argue that that is in favor of the population in favor of the
people that need healthcare. I would argue it's not sustainable though.
It might make it feel good,
but it's not going to do good in the long run because it's still a profit.
Even if they're there, they're having,
they're profiting because they're charging America. Well,
America is basically paying for this. Right, okay. Which is, which is why it's,
which is why it's important for like trade agreements to say, Hey,
you guys have to enforce the same patent laws that we have otherwise, this,
this is not sustainable situation because eventually you don't make a profit.
Right. Right. And that's, and that's not fair for Americans.
So the new NAFTA deal was negotiated this way. The U S MCA,
like addressing some of these concerns, for instance. Uh, and that's,
that's the right thing to do. Like you ha you have to,
you have to align a set incentives when you're talking about any policy and we
have to dig a few layers. It's never as simple as Bernie Sanders says it is.
It never is. He always makes it out to be so simple. That's greed.
Everything is attributable to greed.
Everything is attributable to the 1% they own you. They, they,
they own the lobbyists, they own all this. Listen,
there's elements of truth in all of that, but what my point is,
it's just not the overarching thing.
There's so much more complexities to that and we have to have those
conversations and like we're just, we're, we're, we're,
instead what we see is just very extreme talking points. First of all,
very extreme interpretations of the actual problem and therefore leading to very
extreme solutions to that problem, right?
If you say the world's ending in 12 years, then why not have a green new deal?
Right? Like it's a,
you're operating off of a premise that is highly extreme and, uh, and it just,
it's not, it's not healthy political discourse. It's meant to an animate people.
It's meant to get people upset and to have a villain. Again,
it always comes back to the villain and the oppressor and oppressed.
It always comes back to this. Everything.
Everything's somebody like Bernie Sanders says,
can be traced to this specific ideology where one person is to blame or one
institution is to blame.
And I think that's extremely unhealthy way to look at things.
And also intellectually dishonest.
I don't know the parameters of a green new deal,
the new green deal or whatever the fuck it is, but you hear it all the time.
What, what is the idea behind this? Uh, at its core,
a, a complete shift to wind and solar, uh, at its core. So, uh,
an idea that if you do that, you will,
you will have zero emissions in the next 10 years.
But it's an obsession with wind and solar,
which I think is interesting in band's nuclear.
We remember when the talking points came out from the green new deal didn't like
nuclear. So that's how, you know,
it's not an actual environmental plan or at least, uh,
associated with carbon emissions and climate change.
Because why would you ban the,
the one reliable piece of energy that we have that has zero emissions,
which is nuclear. So, you know, it's not about that.
It also includes free healthcare for everybody. It includes free college.
So it's like,
it's like every socialist plan wrapped into one and then they call it an
environmental plan and ban fossil fuels and things like that.
So that's a fundamentally what it is. It's a wishlist of, of things like that.
Well, nuclear has this inherent fear of things going wrong. Chernobyl. Yeah.
You know, there is shame and that kind of stuff.
We also put nuclear reactors on like submarines and put a bunch of people on
them and you go down to depths and put torpedoes and stuff on them.
So I mean it's sure whelming very safe amount of nuclear energy that's been used
in this country versus the amount of times we've had nuclear disasters.
And there's also the problem with these old systems that weren't like Fukushima
that were implemented in the 1960s and 1970s they just, they're not as good.
Yeah, we just, that's true. But we, we do have the technology to make them good.
And,
and I think we should look at ways to research more the miniaturized mountain
modular nuclear devices that are, that are being looked at in nuclear car.
Maybe we can get you, Oh shit. I don't have them yet.
You should have a nuclear card judge. You have a nuclear cars.
What about a nuclear one's lame thrower. Now we're getting crazy. Um,
so then the new green deals just wind and solar.
It concentrates on just windmills and solar.
And then the idea is to replace the grid with some sort of mean California.
It seems like it could be possible.
Like you could just put solar panels on everybody's roof in California.
You'd probably reduce the amount of that we need from the grid radically.
Yeah. It gets complicated because you don't have sun at night. And, uh,
and so this is the complication of wind and solar in general, is that the,
you need battery backup to really make this work and that technology just isn't
there. Um, the theoretical, it's just not there. I mean we would,
we mean you'd have, you'd have to off the grid with solar power. Right.
But you to make this, uh, to do that. But when they don't, like I said,
when there is no sun, the plants shift to either, you know,
natural gas or coal or something else. Here, this is a perfect example.
Like here, this is a goofy place to live cause it doesn't rain.
We have sun every day but not at night. And so, so this is,
but 12 hours sun is enough will only if you have the batteries,
only if you other the batteries to store it. And so yeah, in theory if you,
if you, that we did and we don't right now, like for if you actually,
if you want to, if you want to shift the entire energy grid to that,
we do not have this, the massive amounts of, there's some good data on this.
I don't have it off the top of my head. It's massive.
It is massive amount of batteries and farms to actually hold that.
There's an energy density problem with wind and solar is the physics problem.
So the science can only go so far and even the theoretical limit to how much a
battery can hold probably were, which were not even we haven't discovered yet,
but it's a theoretical like capacity of a battery, uh,
it would still make it very difficult to actually do this. And so it's,
it's just not realistic. Uh,
also also there's other consequences to wind and solar, like massive, you know,
solar term or wind turbines. Okay.
Those are some people don't like those things. Uh,
massive amounts of space needed for, for, for solar.
And also where are you going to get that? That the, the, the,
the special materials needed for solar panels. Like there's,
there's other consequences to this. Um, and it's, it's,
it's not self evident that that's the only possible way to do it. It's not,
it's not like we should shun it. Okay.
Then nobody's saying that it should we advocate for all the above approach.
If our goal is less carbon emissions than we need to be focusing on 100% of
carbon emissions, meaning the world's carbon emissions,
the green new deal focuses on 15% of carbon emissions. Basically says,
let's kneecap the United States economy will a will destroy fossil fuels,
will have a utopian society full of wind and solar,
even though the batteries don't exist to make that work. But Hey,
we'll make it work.
So then that then that's all is 15% of the problem and has almost no effect on,
on the actual climate. So when I say 100% of the problem,
what I'm saying is technological innovation,
whether it's nuclear or carbon capture,
if the goal is less carbon than let's actually focus on carbon capture.
So I just dropped a bill, uh, Senator Cornyn did on the,
on the Senate side called the leading act and it basically re repurposes grant
funds in the department of energy to focus on carbon capture for natural gas
plants. So we have natural gas plants in Texas that are zero emissions.
They take in natural gas, they operate the facility, they create electricity,
and then they recapture that carbon and they power the facility with it.
Zero emissions. So if our goal is zero emissions, let's do what works.
And also by the way, that plant can keep going. Matter. What does that matter?
What time of day it? I didn't know that that existed. That's amazing.
Call net power. We talked about something on the podcast before. Just as a joke.
I was saying, why don't they just make a giant building but make an air filter?
Like a huge building the size of an air filter but a carbon capture. Yeah,
huge air filter. The size of a building. But apparently they're doing that.
Apparently China is in the process of building things like that.
I've heard of some things in China to think [inaudible] because they have an air
pollution problem that's different from carbon. Okay.
So like cause carbon dioxide, you're breathing it right now.
You're not polluting it, right, necessarily.
So they've got a different problem and they're just a mess. And so I,
that might be what they're doing. But the co on the carbon capture side,
it's definitely happening.
It's all the oil companies actually doing it because there's actually an
interest in the oil and gas industry to reduce carbon emissions.
There's a huge interest. I mean they,
they realize where the conversation is going and we should encourage that.
You know?
So there's pretty impressive big projects going on by a lot by a lot of these by
a lot of these folks. So your take is that what the green new deal is? I mean,
if I can encapsulate it, your, the,
the green new deal is basically more of an emotional plea to people that are
worried about the future and that sea wind and solar as being free and clean
alternatives. It's a dogmatic approach to this. It's not based in,
makes people feel good. It's a,
it's a feel good thing and it really shouldn't make them feel good,
but just evolved consequences I said about, well, wind and solar, it's not,
these aren't necessarily clean by themselves.
It also involves conflict minerals, right. That you need for these,
that's what I was getting at too. Yeah. Like w where do you,
where do you mind these things? It's not, it's not the United States.
It's not the United States where we have child labor laws. Janice Stans,
the Congo is a lot,
a lot of places that have these good intentions often lead to bad things.
So look at the ethanol issue.
When we decided that we wanted ethanol in our gasoline, well I think it was,
I want to say it's Indonesia and Malaysia,
but they cleared tons and tons of forest to, to make room,
um, so that they could so that they could, uh, produce the ethanol oil.
All right. Carbon emissions there increase rapidly because of that, you know,
all because of our good intentions and like these incentives in the second third
order effects, they matter. And we have to think about them when we're,
when we're talking about policy and if our goal again,
is if our goal is less emissions than let's,
let's be thoughtful about how we approach that.
Let's not decide on a solution and then look for reasons to back up that
solution. Um,
is there any other things that are on the horizon that makes sense in terms of
trying to mitigate all of the,
the problems that we have with carbon emissions in this country? Like is there,
is there anything else that people were working on? Uh, I listed a lot on the,
the carbon capture technology I think is the most promising because it's
profitable. You can sell carbon. Oh there's a lot.
There's a big market for carbon so they can use it in cities.
Like can they use it other places other than plants.
Like you were talking about the natural gas plants, you want to focus,
you want to focus something like carbon capture on the places that admit the
most carbon. This, that's why it's generally focused on the, the,
the plants themselves.
I think so like something like net power just makes the most sense. Um,
yeah. So I, I think that's still the, the right way to go. The,
the other natural gas too. So here's another statistic.
The department of energy has done a study on this.
If D replaced coal burning plants and are the boilers coal burning boilers in
China, in India with natural gas,
meaning we have all the natural gas in the world. By the way, in Texas,
like we can export it for decades to come. It's far cleaner than,
than oil and coal. If you just replaced the China's India's boilers,
you'd reduce, you'd reduced emissions by 40%.
Like the reason the United States has reduced emissions by I think by 15% since
the year 2000 it's because of,
it's largely because of the national natural gas boon that the fracking
business, because it's so much cleaner than,
than these other technologies and it's profitable and it worked.
But when you say fracking, eat immediately red flag. Right.
I saw that movie gas land people are lighting their water on fire.
Like there's obviously consequences to natural gas extraction through fracking
as well, including earthquakes. Yeah, it's pretty rare. And on all the,
all of these factors have to combine for an earthquake to actually happen.
And then also the technology has progressed a huge amount, like I said,
to radically increase the amount of earthquakes in places like Oklahoma just
because of fracking. Yeah.
And they decided that fracking did have something to do with that,
but they've also figured out how to make sure that doesn't happen.
How do they make sure I don't, I don't know that I don't know the details.
I just know well, there's just ways to do it. Like there's, in the early days,
I think there were some problems that the Senate,
the water setting on fire that had nothing to do with fracking as it turned out
that that was debunked. Something else, some kind of methane emission.
It wasn't, wasn't related to the fracking. If I, if I recall, uh, how,
how that conversation ended up playing out the,
that seems like a big factor. I mean,
I feel like we should know what fucked up factor was. I mean, I, I would,
I wouldn't, I, I would say to people like, you know, fracking happens a lot.
It's, it's, the technology has moved on quite a bit. Uh,
it's pretty safe. And there's also,
there's more than the initial implementation of it where they weren't really,
yeah. Yeah. I mean, I wouldn't, I wouldn't argue that it was perfect, you know,
and I know that it was associated with some earthquakes,
but there was a lot of other factors, you know, specific to that place.
Like there's nowhere, there's not earthquakes in Texas that I'm aware of.
And that's where we have in West Texas where we have fried most of this fracking
going on. So I mean just people should know like nuclear power,
like the old plants.
They really didn't know what they were doing and they made some big mistakes.
I think it's probably like any technology, but I would still want to point out,
uh, it's, it caused a huge decrease in emissions. You know, and if we're,
and again, it's over. If we're looking to decrease emissions,
why don't we focus on things that work and,
and you have to hook people on went by people, I mean the world,
especially developing countries that don't care about our dogmatic approach to
wind and solar, they never will. And uh,
but what can you do to help them get energy to keep their people out of poverty
and cause that's what they care
about, uh, in a way that's reliable and cheap and market based.
Cause the only thing that's sustainable is market-based.
Sustainability is an important term here. And I, and I mean that,
not in the sense of like environmental sustainability,
although we are saying the same thing.
I mean it in terms of what policy will last and what will implode.
It's an important question and it's one reason I'm a Republican because our
policies, they don't feel good.
They're not based on emotional reasoning but they are based on realistic
reasoning and sustainability of that policy and this is,
this is a case like that and if you don't and take into account market forces
and incentives and just I think basic human nature,
then we're not doing justice to the problem itself. Now,
one of the big issues that's in the news
right now is the trade war with China.
I mean this is a huge issue and it's made me dive into a lot of a really weird
stuff with Walway and with the Chinese government's involved in and various
corporations and it's a hard concept to grasp for the average American citizen
that the corporations in China are an extra [inaudible] connected to the
communist government and that this is they, they work hand in hand,
they do the bidding of the government,
they work together even though they are profitable, radically profitable.
They also do things specifically at the bidding of the government,
including inserting shit that can allow people to spy on people,
which is why they're banning Walway devices. And this is a,
and it all comes back to what you were talking about earlier to an intellectual
copyright with a, in terms of pharmaceutical drugs,
the same thing could be said about electronics.
I mean there's entire Apple stores in China that have nothing to do with Apple.
They don't even, they just make their own stuff and call it Apple stuff.
Thieves. Yeah. It's very strange. Right. What,
what do you think about this sort of like tug of war that's going on right now
that we're seeing play out publicly?
Well, I,
I think that Chinese deserve every bit of it for all the reasons you just
stated.
Their intellectual property theft is rampant and it has been for a very long
time.
And we've been in this position where our business community doesn't want to
bash them too bad because they want that market to be opened up and they'll,
and they'll,
there'll be very conciliatory to whatever the Chinese want a in order to get
openings to that market. And, uh, you know, this is the,
and Trump is the first to really saying, no, this is the enough is enough. Um,
I've, I've, and so while I'm [inaudible],
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but you think that's because he's the first person that actually has a
background in business, like real big business.
That could be it, that could be at I, I don't, I don't know why exactly,
but I know he's doing it. So yeah,
he's been talking about this for a very long time. This isn't new to him.
Talking about this in the 90s. He was, yeah. And, uh,
and I, I'm not overly sympathetic to trade Wars, especially with our allies.
And I was happy to see us getting to a deal with Canada and Mexico.
I don't see a point in, in strong arming them,
but with China I'm much more sympathetic to it. And uh,
and I think that that should largely be bipartisan.
And you don't even see Democrats slamming Trump too much for this. Uh,
but there are consequences. And so I,
I would like the president to be more forthright about, listen,
we are going to feel some pain too because when you implement tariffs,
you're affecting people's supply chains. And when you do that,
you're hurting American businesses too. Right?
There has to be a reason for that. Okay.
And the reason is the Chinese are bad actors and we are,
we are in sort of an economic cold war with them.
The Chinese think in 50 year terms, we think in four year terms,
they have a huge advantage in the sense they have union advantage that they can
prop up their businesses and, and, and, and, and,
and put forth their belt and road initiatives and,
and made in China 2025 I think is, might be getting that wrong.
But you know, they can,
they can manipulate public opinion to encourage those status policies.
And there's disadvantages to that too. It means they're much less dynamic.
The fact that they steal everything means they'll never be competitive.
They're not truly a great, you know, great nation,
the way they're making themselves out to be because they're thieves.
And I think we should point that out. But we are in this cultural war with them.
We are in this economic cold war with them. And that's, that's,
that's nothing new, but it is coming to the forefront.
And so we gotta be careful. I would prefer, you know,
we take fights to the WTO.
We actually have a good history of being successful in the WTO against the
Chinese. Uh, and we go after singular companies like Walway, uh,
that w that would, I would like to see that. Um, you know, again,
I'm sympathetic to the tariffs, but they do hurt us. They hurt us.
There are a lot of people in my district, Texas is a, a good, uh,
competitive market. We do well when there's free competition.
And so we tend to want more free trade and more free competition cause we know
we can handle it. Uh, so, so when there's not that it, it,
it can tend to hurt because we have very complex supply chains throughout the
world.
And then we have to take note of that what seems like a game of chicken almost.
[inaudible] yeah, that's what it seems like back and forth.
It's like who's going to blink? It is like that. Yeah. That's so crazy.
Then international business gets done and it seems so bizarre to a dummy like me
sitting on the sidelines going, what are these guys doing? And there's,
there's no playbook that tells you exactly how you should go forth with this.
And they just, you know, and so, um, there's,
this isn't, um, and um, it makes it harder.
You've got to take a lot of things into account and have a good end goal in
mind. And I think, I think we could do a better job of having that. But, um,
but in the end, I think, again, as a holistically,
I'm more sympathetic to being hard on the Chinese.
I'm realizing as we're talking that I never really a continued my thoughts on
the censorship in the media.
And I wanted to know what you think could be done in terms of how,
how you could stop,
particularly conservative voices from being silenced on social media and what
can be done. Do you think that like government regulation should be enacted?
Like what, what should be done to stop? Cause there's a bunch of stuff that's
gone on behind the scenes shadow banning and you know, you don't,
what do you think about that? So there uh,
Senator Holly is looking at some legislation in the Senate on this and it, it,
and I want to get in too much detail cause I don't wanna screw up the exact
details of this,
but it essentially gets at section two 30 which provides protections for,
uh, internet platforms, right? Like you can't be sued for liable.
Like whatever you post on Facebook is not Facebook's fault. Okay. So that's,
it protects them in a way [inaudible] and as it should frankly.
Cause how could it be Facebook's fault? Like,
if you have a crazy comment on your YouTube videos that your fault,
they were trying to enact that for a while there they released something saying
that we had to be in charge of the comments on our page. Remember that?
It's crazy. Jamie and I talked about it. I was like,
we're just going to shut the comments down cause otherwise we're going to go to
jail. Yes, it's fucking crazy.
People are constantly posting nutty things, right? And they're like,
and why is it a YouTube fall? Why is it your fault? Exactly.
You know you were going to be response where, where's the blame lie?
And so like that's, that's why off of that. So as they should. So that's,
that's that conversation is the conversation of what is the platform,
what does a publication, because you can see the New York times, right? If they,
if they publish something that you don't like. Okay.
So the problem we're seeing is that Facebook, in Twitter,
they're acting like both. They're getting,
they're trying to get the best of both worlds,
where they're this like open platform,
but then they can also decide and kind of act like a publisher and decide what
kind of content is allowed on that platform. And the,
and the problem is the standards they're using are utterly vague and IM and
subjective and then politically biased obviously.
And so like that's a real problem. And so I think,
I think this legislation might get at kind of removing that protection and
basically allowing someone to say, Hey, you're being libelous.
And once that incentive is there, it's like, okay,
there's a better incentive now to say we are a pure platform. Uh,
you know, we'll,
we have to have much stronger standards in the sense of clearer standards.
You know, maybe it's a word that you don't allow, I don't know,
but at least be specific. Cause right now it's like, you know,
they define hate speech in the Vegas terms possible.
And then they moved the boundaries all the time.
Like now you can get banned for life or dead naming someone,
which means like if I,
if I wrote something about Bruce general is cute in these heels.
If I wrote that I could get deadname banned for life from Twitter.
Like literally if I write Bruce Jenner looks cute and these heels, Oh,
because he's not personally, I understand him. His son called him,
he hilarious and that uh, whoops, one of the, what was it?
The Hills and the Hills came back. Oh yeah, he's, yeah, his son is on,
I think it took a lot of heat for it cause he called his dad and he said my dad
when he became one, what the fuck is dad? What's he supposed to say?
That's his actual dad. I told him, I don't know, but that's where we've,
we've entered into this cuckoo land. You know,
you can get banned for life for deadnaming. But again, OJ Simpson,
hello Twitter world. Yeah. You know, fucking kills people and he's on there.
No violation in terms of, we looked at the terms of service,
it seems like you're fine. Mr. Simpson,
please rant about politics in the draft NFL draft and we want to hear your,
your, your pics. I don't follow him. They're gay. It's fucking awesome. Well,
Stan hope and I had an idea of way back when we were, uh, hosting the man show.
We had this idea to have OJ Simpson. This is after he got acquitted,
the man show we were going to Brown spots and we were going to have OJ Simpson
and wrap up every episode like Mickey Rooney. You know,
Mickey Rooney sorta gives his, wow. Why is toothpastes always come at tube?
You remember that making Rooney's little Mickey Rooney.
What the fuck's his name? Andy Rooney. Andy Rose. He was the actor,
but Andy Rooney would, uh, we were going to have him. OJ Simpson.
Just give some sort of down-home anecdote at the end of every episode.
Sorta tie everything up and let you know that this fucking show is bananas.
But then the whole murderer thing. No, the burger thing was before.
This was way after the murderer thing. This isn't like 2002. Okay. But then,
you know, they, the comedy central shot it down,
but now you can actually get that on Twitter. I mean that is what he's doing.
He's, he's intending like, you never murdered anybody. Right.
And he's just a hello Twitter world and he's doing this thing. Well,
I mean made ads. It's not clear to me that we should ban him. You know,
like why, why would we cause cause again, right. Let's again,
free speech is a very specifically protected thing and it matters to us.
This is the question, is it free speech when it's a company that owns,
they own this platform,
should they be allowed to create their own rules?
Because this is what Twitter's done. This is what Facebook's done.
This is what Instagram has done.
They've created their own rules as to what is and what is not acceptable. Yeah.
And that, that's,
that's the heart of the question because we've never dealt with this because the
first amendment was always created to protect you from government infringing on
your speech.
Because we always assumed that government would be the only thing powerful
enough to actually infringe on your free speech. Right? We never,
we forgot about this other world that we now live in. We didn't forget about it,
we just didn't know about it. Where there are other entities that have very,
very powerful abilities to actually infringe on your free speech.
And it's, but like you said, they are private entities.
And so is it really up to government to tell the private entity,
are we enforcing the spirit of the first amendment or are we enforcing the first
amendment according to protecting you from government? Right. And so,
but then that's an interesting question. Are we,
should we enforce the spirit of the first amendment,
which certainly think we're encouraging it. I mean, I,
I've definitely very vocal about encouraging it. And I say, you don't have a,
I and I, when Google was in front of me in a hearing the other day, uh, I said,
and it was Google, all of them were there. I said,
you don't have a legal obligation to do what I'm telling you,
but I do think you have an American obligation to actually adhere to free speech
standards and to adhere to the same standards as the government adheres to,
which is your speech is not protected if it incites violence directly is a
pretty clear standard. Yes. Uh,
everything else is entirely vague and it only leads to a slippery slope and
frankly,
a very dangerous situation where we're just at each other's throats even worse
because not only are you yelling at each other,
but you're telling certain people that their opinions are just utterly
unacceptable and can't be heard at all. If you want to create civil war,
that's a really quick way to do it, right?
When you really disenfranchise people and it's just so dangerous and we just
shouldn't do it.
I fully agree and I really appreciate the way you were holding their heels to
the fire on that,
particularly in regards to the description of people being Nazis, right?
That was you. You were talking about Dennis Prager and Ben Shapiro,
who are Jewish gentlemen,
who were being labeled Nazis by internal memos and was Google. Uh,
that was Google. Yeah. Yeah. And it's so intellectually dishonest.
So intellectually dishonest. And not only that, no, no pushback internally. Oh,
also, you know, I always, I always tell people when, when, when they're,
when they're complaining about something Trump said and they're like,
look at the violence he's inciting, all right. And I say, well,
you call us all Nazis. When you call somebody a Nazi, you,
you are calling somebody something that we agreed as Americans to bomb and kill
and destroy.
So you're labeling me with a label that we all agree should be destroyed.
Like how is that not inciting violence by your, by your, by your standards.
I mean it's, you take away that name,
you take away the word Nazi and there's far less targets for people to be upset
about. I mean, if you just stop using that word,
stop using the word Nazi and look,
there are clearly real white nationalists who saw that in Charlottesville and
those dorks showed up and Tiki torches. Yeah. Those are real white nationalists.
They were the real, yeah. There's a lot of people that are not Ben Shapiro's,
one of them. You know, you can't, and not even close, not even close.
Like it's not even, yeah, it's,
but it's this convenient label that once you decide that someone is the other
dehumanize them,
their perspective becomes intolerable and you can label them as being this,
this target. Right, right. And they, they do it to Trump too. I mean, Trump,
you know,
this continues to be said by basically everybody running for president, uh,
that Trump has a white supremacist and,
and white ceramist and Nazi or practically basically, I think the same thing.
I think we have a,
we have an understandably deep objection to anything white supremacist as we
should. It should be condemned. Totally.
And when you're calling the president that I think you're also therefore,
and they often call us supporters that too. Yeah.
So you're calling 60 something million people who voted for him. The same thing.
I just,
I just can't imagine a worst way to engage in dialogue and a quicker way to
escalate things to, to just the worst possible scenario. But it's new.
This is not something that existed 10 years ago.
People didn't run around calling everyone a Nazi. Like what happened? How did,
how did the word Nazi get tossed around
like a beach ball at a concert because it's so free to use now and people on the
left are the ones who are using it.
It's not people on the right or labeling left wing people Nazis,
but fascist and Nazi that were just gets thrown out without any real
comprehension or any real responsibility for the actual definition of it.
Yeah. And I don't know where the origin is.
Um, well the origin years it is,
and then they found the word and they liked it. They just,
they found something effective, I think. Um, you know, there's,
there's Herbert Marcuse is sort of the,
one of the original thinkers from the new left who said that like the new way of
progressivism needs to be dividing people up into that other, okay. And then,
and then not only that, but but labeling them and then suppressing their speech.
So this started in the 60s okay. This the sort of the policy,
this is like a left wing thinker, right? Okay. So his,
his ideas,
this was absolutely a strategy that he was right and an actual strategy of
suppression because the goal was to take the previously oppressed and suppress
the previous oppressors. This is how, this is how they talked about it.
So this isn't slave the slave owners, right. So this is in a sense,
this isn't new like this. This is the kind of radicalism we're seeing.
It started in the 60s it was imbued into our universities and now we're seeing
it manifest again and amplified.
I think by social media and labeling somebody a Nazi is just really an old
tactic. They're just using a different word. And I don't know,
I think if we were, I think if we looked into history,
there's probably other cases where they've continued to call us Nazis,
but it's obviously extremely prevalent now. I mean never to this extent. Right.
And I just, I don't know why that it, well, it's,
it's the rise of identity politics fundamentally. And so, and then there was,
and then I think there's, it's fair. It is because the left would say, well,
there was a,
there was kind of a white identity politics rise and they were given some kind
of voice by Donald Trump. Right? This is what they would say.
And I think that there's probably some truth to that and then that's terrible.
But I think that, I think that was a reaction, you know, uh,
we should always point out that like when you do surveys of what race,
race relations are like in America,
they were much better before than they are now.
And do we really think we've gotten more racist, you know, like what happened?
And this is under president Obama's presidency. And I,
and I think those identity,
that identity politics just came to the forefront in the last decade in a really
terrible way. And again,
I think identity politics is one of the worst things we could do to each other.
Um, when you divide people up into different groups and,
and talk about intersectional hierarchies of victimhood, I just think it's, I,
I, it's, it's just dividing because fundamentally what it is,
is you're dividing people up and you're saying your group is oppressed by that
group and if you vote for me, I'll give you power over that group. Yeah.
And you can trace a lot of, of, of policies to that.
And this all stems from Marxists ideology where it was more socioeconomic
division of, but
that is, but that has become, uh,
an ideology of intersectionality, uh,
ironically put forth by a woman named Crenshaw.
Really? Yeah. I kept Kimberly Crenshaw.
I think she came at it from a much more academic standpoint. I think it's,
I think whatever her original theory of intersectionality was a,
has been transformed quite a bit. But yeah,
I find that interesting cause I'm still opposed to that, you know,
now that I'm thinking about it, I don't even think it's 10 years.
I think the Nazi thing is only about four or five years old to the extent we're
seeing it. Sure. Yeah. You know, and so strange. And people use it so freely.
I look at people on Twitter use it so freely and they use it in regards to my
guests and you know, they use it say that I've had Nazis on the show. Like,
what do you mean? I'm like, this is crazy. You know, you're,
you're calling the Jewish man in Nazi.
You can an Orthodox Jewish guy wears a yamaka. You calling them a Nazi, right?
The fucking bananas. It just doesn't make any sense.
And we just added the shameless about it. The shameless about these accusations.
I don't understand it. Here's something we're probably going to disagree about.
A recreational marijuana. You are apparently, no kidding.
I really thought we're going to do a whole show with Joe Rogan and you weren't
going to bring up marijuana. Like what are the chances
you're not in favor of recreational marijuana? No, I can, I can be convinced,
but I'm not there yet right now. Well, spark one up. I,
I don't like it. I just, I just don't like it. I liked,
I like scotch like that too. We got shot of that.
We've had scotch to this whole time. Well, you gave me this amazing,
you gave me this amazing coffee that's actually Hamilton's savory food, coffee.
It's pretty damn good. Right? Need me maybe so coherent like, yeah, I love it.
The clarity. Good. Well it's got a tumeric. It's, it reduces inflammation.
Right? It gives you a yellow list though. So I, I'm definitely,
I'm definitely more open to just the federal legalization of medical marijuana
and all the benefits that come with that.
I think the science backs that up pretty well. Sure. The,
I'm on the recreational side, I'm happy to leave that to the States. Okay.
And then there's the argument of, well,
the States are having trouble with some things, the banking laws, et cetera,
because the federal government doesn't, may still makes it illegal. My, my,
my issue with recreational marijuana still is, is it's, and again,
this is not a strong opinion and I have,
this is not a Hill I'm dying on by any means. Um,
but if we're going to change it,
I want to understand what the point is and like what the benefits are of it
recreationally. I understand the benefits medically very well. Uh,
but I don't understand the, the recreational benefits.
And I want to see how this data plays out in places like California and
Colorado. You know,
I want to see if there's an increased use among young people. Cause there's,
there's,
there's very good science that says if you use marijuana a lot under the age of
26,
you're going to have cognitive issues for the rest of your life along with yes.
Yeah. But it is legal and people compare those things.
But I am my counter isn't that my counter is simply this,
the alcohol issues out of the bag, like it just is, you know,
we're never going to put that back in. Um,
and so I think they're gonna put pot back in the bag. Well, not necessarily.
My point is this,
there's a normalization that occurs when you legalize something. You're telling,
okay, so let's say make the age 21 or a, I'm not, what is it in California? Um,
I think it's 21 is it? So let's say, I want to think it's the same as alcohol,
let's say make it 21 what you've done though is you've normalized it for
teenagers cause you said, well yeah it's 21 but it's legal so there's nothing,
there's no issues with it. Okay.
That's what your T I think that's what you're telling people.
And there's a lot of people who can just live their lives extremely productively
and smoked pot a lot. And there's a lot of people who can't. Okay.
And there's lot of people who don't. Those people are lazy bitches. Well yeah,
let me help you. You can live your life. You just listen.
Pot's not for everybody. And I have a lot of friends who don't smoke pot,
but pot is a tool. Just like a hammer. You can build a house with a hammer,
you could hit yourself in the Dick if you're fucking crazy like scotch.
You could drink scotch recreationally.
You can have a couple of glasses with some friends and have a great
conversation. And it's a social lubricant and people enjoy a nice enjoy.
And that's why we've got a bunch of bottles of it over there. A look. But,
but don't you have to drink way more scotch to get even close to the,
to the basically cognitive and coherence that you'd be able to just one bite of
a brownie. You, you would, but not me.
I smoked pot all the time. I could smoke pot.
I could've smoked pot before this podcast and the exact same podcast.
I could have had several hits. If I gave you several hits,
you'd be obliterated and you'd be so paranoid, freaking out,
and you'd think the government's coming to get you and you're going to close
down the Congress and Oh my God, I try to listen. Anyway,
it's, it's, um, a lot of it is based on our own ideas and perceptions.
And I had a lot of these misconceptions in my own head. I didn't really,
I smoked pot maybe six times or so,
seven times before I was 30 years old.
And then when I was 30 I started hanging around with a guy, smoked a lot,
my friend Eddie Bravo, we started smoking pot together and I realized like, Oh,
this is an incredible tool for creativity. Like if you use it correctly.
And yeah, it makes you paranoid,
but I think a lot of what that paranoia is is you being acutely aware of your
vulnerability and your actual real place in the cosmos and your real place in
society and the real dangers of driving cars and the real dangers of being in
crowds of people. Yeah, it's not, it's a weird, uncomfortable feeling,
but ultimately you get through that and you're going to be okay and in a culture
that I just don't really have a problem with what you're saying. You know,
like it's, I'm just, I'm not cultural, I guess on a personal level,
I'm just not opposed to what you're saying at all. Uh,
from a policy level though, I just look at things differently.
Like when I extracted myself from the personal situations I've had with pot,
and I look at it from a policy perspective, what personal situations I do.
I've tried it, you know, and they're annoyed. I don't like it. I didn't,
I really don't freak out. I don't know. No, I'm not a freak out here.
I'm not a freak out kind of person. But what didn't you like? Uh, and it just,
it's just the sensation that just in general, I just really didn't like it. Um,
I don't know how much did you smoke? Too much. What? Sorry?
I think there's something going out with my headphones with that gloss over
this. So, but here's the problem with keeping an illegal criminal. Sell it.
I mean, this the same problem we had during prohibition.
This is what propped up the mom, right? We all know this, and this is a,
this is the number one problem we have with the Mexican drug cartels.
And the number one problem is that there's a goddamn customer base in the United
States and they're making billions and billions of dollars selling illegal
drugs. And what's the solution to that? I don't know. I mean not, look, I don't,
I have kids.
I don't want fucking heroin to be something you could buy at seven 11 yeah.
I don't want you to be able to go to a store and buy meth, you know?
But I guess it'll hold another conversation about all drugs. All drugs. Yeah.
But those are the real dangerous ones. Pots, not that.
And when you lie to kids and tell them that pots the real,
real danger and you shouldn't do it, then they start going,
well maybe you're lying about heroin. Maybe you're lying about math.
Maybe just square, maybe just some loser.
Just wants to be stuck in a cubicle all day and you want me to be living like
look you. But it does reduce,
I mean it does reduce in productivity I think more than alcohol does when
[inaudible] dependent upon the person.
I get paranoid and I want to do more things cause I don't want to be a loser.
That's what happens to me when I smoked pot.
I think it accentuates many aspects of people that are already lazy.
If you are already lazy and you have a problem with discipline, which I don't,
if you have a problem with discipline and you smoke pot, yeah, yeah.
You're going to just want to veg out, line the grass and stare at the sky.
The clouds. I want to get going. Yeah. I smoked pot and go to the gym. I mean,
I do it all the time. And again, as a policy maker though,
I have to look at the whole situation. So I see people like you and you're like,
yeah, you'd be fine. Why not? Um, but I, I,
but I do have to take into account the entirety of the situation and asked
myself, well, what is the benefit of society society doing this?
Like what is the people nicer in enhances a sense of community.
It makes people more aware of their surroundings. Kinder people. I mean,
I don't know. I think alcohol is much more of a social lubricant.
Definitely makes him meaner too. But I mean,
as far as getting along with people and going out and,
and interacting with human difference, it's different. But definitely, yes.
Inhibits your inhibitions. It lowers your inhibitions.
So it allows you to talk more freely with people.
Definitely encourages more sex and more terrible decision making and driving
too.
But the thing about marijuana and other policy problems because like how do you
test for it? You know, we have a very kind of clear standards on alcoholics.
Just again, it's like, again, I'm not, I'm not just not dying on this Hill. Um,
I just, I have questions and those questions aren't answered. I understand that.
But it's questions oftentimes are coming from a place of propaganda.
Like people have this idea of what it is versus what it really is. I don't know.
I,
I have personal experience with this and know I'm 35 so like growing up around
this my entire life, this isn't so, it's not some,
again, did you do it right? But here's the thing,
it's the same thing with alcohol. You could have led, driven,
drunk and crashed your car and go, well, alcohol's bad. Look,
I drove car into a fucking tree and I go, well, Hey man,
I just had a couple beers with my friends and we had a great old time.
We laughed it up and nobody got hurt. The difference is again, again,
the way to, to measure how much too alcohol,
too much alcohol is well defined and all that.
We also have just hundreds of years of experience with like as a culture with
how to figure out alcohol and how to deal with this to have thousands of years
of experience of how to use cannabis.
But it was suppressed in the 1930s by William Randolph Hearst and Harry
Anslinger and more of an echo economic decision.
It was a public health decision. Yeah,
and I think I've heard your podcast on that. It's interesting. Yeah,
there's many, many documentaries and books written on it,
but I think that the real problem is when you make drugs illegal,
only Outlaws sell drugs. You prop up illegal enterprises.
It's a guy coming in next, next month or next week, rather John Norris, who,
uh, is a, a guy who, uh, works for the state.
He's one of those guys that has to go around and find these illegal grow ops on
public land and it's fucking extremely dangerous. Yeah. I mean,
bottom bottom line is my, my position is that's a state decision. You know,
it's a state decision and not federally.
Why wouldn't it be federally legal if alcohol's federally illegal,
if we'd know that no one's dying from it, no one can overturn that.
I just want to see what the data comes out as from Colorado.
It's mixed right now. Frankly,
I think we need a strong education program to let people know, first of all,
if you have a problem with reality, if you have schizophrenia in your family,
if your reality's already slippery, marijuana is not for you.
And I've personally seen people that have struggled that that do have an adverse
reaction to marijuana and they go off the fucking rails. It does happen. Yeah.
It's particularly with edibles,
edibles in particular to knock people for a loop.
But then there's other people that doesn't do that too. And I think we,
the the way to study that is to have actual funding and make it legal.
Where you could, you could look at things across the board and figure out why.
I think, I think as far as the battles we should fight in the federal level,
we've got to start with the medical side. I think this,
I think the science is clear and like, so you know, let's start, I mean I,
I just, I just the gateway, right?
CBD is non-psychoactive and helps so many old people with arthritis and so many
people with anxiety. It's fantastic. And it just is, again,
another reason I'm a Republican is because I believe in somewhat slower
policymaking to like these,
these conversations have to play out in society and they,
we don't always need to see to solve the problem right away.
Like there's a reason for that. Things must happen so early. So I think,
I think the medical conversation is, is the one we should be fighting for.
I think the recreational side is a few steps beyond that.
And then we get to that and we'll have them, we'll know more. And I,
and I think that's, that's, that's why generally when people ask me that,
I'm like, this is the medical thing is the thing to be talking about right now.
I appreciate that conservative perspective and the slow approach to things.
And I understand what you're saying.
What bothers me more than anything is that American citizens are not doing any
harm to anyone.
Could be criminals for something that's been used by human beings for thousands
years and doesn't show any real problems.
I don't think young people should drink, but I drank when I was young.
I mean I didn't drink a lot, but I did occasionally.
I don't think young people should smoke pot. I definitely don't encourage it.
No. Matter of fact, I deeply discourage it and I tell people, look,
there's a reason.
One of the reasons why I enjoy it is I didn't start smoking really until I was
30 and you know, I take time off all the time.
It's not an addictive substance to me.
It's psychologically addictive to some people.
And there might be some evidence that a very, very small percentage of people,
it's physically addictive but not like alcohol is or not like a lot of the
things that we can just by anywhere are, yeah, those are all fair arguments.
Again, it's a good discussion to have. I'm not, we sorta disagree on it, but,
but only because I just think more due diligence needs to be done. It's not as,
is not a something I'm vehemently opposed to. Well,
I think anything for young kids can be a real problem,
especially for young kids where their brain is still developing and they're
trying to find their way through life and you give them something that's
severely distorts reality, whatever it is. Um,
I wish we had that same due diligence the way they prescribed psychotropic drugs
to kids because we don't, you know, should talk to parents discretion.
So many parents are putting their kids on Ritalin and Prozac and Adderall and
you know,
and you're making kids speed freaks as opposed to relying on like cognitive
behavioral therapy,
which is proven to work much better because you're getting at the problem,
you're questioning, you're questioning the untruth that you're telling yourself.
That's it. That's effectively what CVT is. Um, you know, it's good practice.
Kids have exorbitant amounts of energy and you can call that hyperactive or you
could just say, well, that kid's got a fucking great engine. Got a lot of gas.
Yeah. You just figure out a way to get this kid engaged in what they like.
I guarantee you'd take that kid, put them in front of a video game.
He doesn't have any problem focusing. Yeah. What did,
what he has a problem with his shitty classes with boring subjects, right.
And teachers that are uninterested and so many people are being labeled as being
problems because of this
blame something else besides reality. And that's, that's, that's,
that's problematic. Um, and uh, you know,
you talked about looking into certain drugs. I mean,
you know the opioid epidemics and issue too where,
and that's a bipartisan issue. It's just, again, it's not exactly clear.
How do you solve this? How do you solve this?
I have a ton of experience with opioids because I've been injured so many times.
Did you ever have a problem getting off of them once you Oh yeah.
It's devastating. It's absolutely, absolutely devastating. And I didn't,
I never knew.
And this was in 2012 so I didn't know how devastating it would be cause I just
stopped taking them. I don't think I'm in pain anymore.
I should probably just not take these. And then I was in, in worse pain.
I had no was sick. I didn't know what was wrong with me.
What was that experience like? Uh, it's not, you just, you can't move.
You're sick. I don't know how to describe it. You're just really sick.
And is your body craving the pills? Yeah, but, but I didn't know that.
I think so. You're just feeling the sickness, just feeling the sickness.
That wasn't, I didn't, I didn't quite know where it was coming from. Um,
and then, you know, you tell your doctor and be like, Oh yeah,
you've got to wean off of that. We tell you that. No,
you didn't tell me that. Um, it's very, I was 28 when this happened,
so I, my body can get over it.
You're also 28 with a strong mind who's a seal. Right.
But the age matters just like it matters with pot and just like,
it matters with addiction, your mind when,
when teenagers are hooked on opioids,
when not one dealer gets into the system,
like you change that person's brain forever and they're always addicted to it,
really bad ways and like it's different the way that I'll always remember it.
Like it's ingrained in my brain too, but it's different cause I was older.
Like if you got an injury today, would you be raise?
Would you be reluctant to take them? No, no. I have faith in my ability to,
to just stacked responsibly. Like I, yeah. You know,
and so that requires a lot of things. But when you win, and this is, this gets,
this is a little bit, gets to the war on drugs philosophy,
like do you just not do it because we're losing all the time.
And I actually disagree with that pretty strongly because [inaudible] yeah,
you might be feel like you're losing all the time, but you are mitigating it.
And supply does create demand, especially with something like opioids.
If that one dealer gets into that one high school and,
and gets those kids addicted at one party,
like those in those kids die 10 12 years later. And I've watched this happen,
I've been to the funerals and uh, it's, it's devastating. And that supply,
that demand was created by supply. So like again, no, there's no,
there's never a black and white to anything.
And so when we say I war on drugs as stupid or it's not stupid, like not,
it's complicated. It's complicated in the opioid epidemic.
I think a good indication of that,
what could be done to mitigate that other than sawing Florida off and selling it
to the Russians, Oh, what did Florida do? Florida is a problem.
You know the whole deal with the pill mills. Did you ever,
there's a great documentary called a,
the Oxy Oxycontin express and detailed how they had pain management centers in
Florida set up right next to the doctor next door to the pharmacy that only sold
opioids. Yeah.
And they didn't realize I was a Florida and they didn't have a database.
They didn't have a database. So there's no computer database. So you could,
if you were a doctor, I could go to you,
I could get my opioids and I'd go over Jamie, he's a doctor.
He could hook me up and then I'd go down the street and get more.
And then when people started selling them, yeah.
And there was an express from Florida went up into Kentucky and Ohio and all
these different students that were having giant problems and they found out the
pills were all coming from this one area. It was a Vanguard documentary.
And that stuff's been slammed down pretty hard ever since. And so,
and the pendulum maybe swung a little too far.
Cause now pain patients are having trouble getting the opioids they want.
They're like, Oh, here's two pills for your surgery. And you're like, really?
Right. Um,
so some people legitimately need this stuff and so we've got to find that
correct balance. And again, you've always got to know why there's a problem. Um,
is a general policy approach.
We should always really question why the problem exists in the first place and,
and, and what the characteristics of that problem are.
So a lot of people are dying, not necessarily, they're not like,
they're not overdosing on oxycotton. They're overdosing
from illegal forms of it or heroin that is laced with fentanyl.
So how do you tackle that? Well, find, I was coming from the Southern border,
that's where it's coming from. Um, you know, we can talk about immigration too,
but little, what happens a lot is, you know,
these massive waves of immigrants who are turning themselves into border patrol,
they're allowed to cross because the drug cartels say they can cross. Okay.
That's why they come across in organized groups.
And then they turned themselves into border patrol and they,
and they claim asylum.
They always bring a kid with them so that they know they can stay.
But what's also happening is just down the road,
the drug cartels are moving the fentinol another or other drugs across,
especially the bulky drugs, mostly like marijuana, things like that.
Fentanyl so small, they can just bring it through trucks,
through ports of entry. So the and,
and so we need sensors to actually detect that and we're getting those,
getting those put in place more. Um,
and we need to secure the border because this is where it's coming from and we
need to deal with where it's coming from South of the border, which is China.
And so the administration actually did that and we got the Chinese to say at
least that they'll do it. And you'll never know how much they're enforcing that.
So we'll see.
It's so interesting when you play people clips of Obama talking about the
importance of securing the border.
I like to play those clips and sounds just like Trump played the statistics of
how many people they sent back and telling people to not come over with their
children. They'll be separated from their children. It's a,
it's one of those things where people like don't like that.
They don't like to see that it really is deeply disturbing to them that Obama
campaigned on this idea of protecting our border cause we all used to agree on
it. You know, [inaudible] racial issue with Trump.
Yeah. I mean he's definitely said some things where you could trip. Yeah. Yeah,
for sure. Definitely not going to [inaudible] raping sides,
murder and not going to defend, not going to defend Trump's rhetoric on the,
on your show or on any show. Um, they contributed to it. Sure.
But again, as a pretty unemotional person, I tend to look at what is the policy.
Right.
And so I have tried my hardest to move the debate towards when it comes to
immigration, towards a matter of sustainability,
a matter of sovereignty and a matter of rule of law. Like,
do we have standards or doing not, you know,
do we believe in this idea of a managed border or do we not? And you know,
in the end, yeah.
And Trump has made the Democrats so crazy that they've moved radically to the
left. And it's interesting to watch.
People always say like both sides have gotten so extreme.
I always find that interesting. And I say this,
there's two ways to manage to measure extremism. One is our voting record.
Like how often do you really vote with the other side?
And you can measure that pretty carefully actually. And you look,
you've probably seen a YouTube video maybe where you watch all over time,
all the red dots and the blue dots and they sort of mingled together and their
voting records. And then they slowly over time moved to the sides.
So both sides are responsible for that.
Like a lack of lack of actual compromise, a lack of deal making where we say,
okay, I'll vote for your stuff. You vote for my stuff, that,
that doesn't happen anymore. A eight. And there's reasons for that.
We could get into, but there's another way to measure extremism.
And it's the actual policy changes. And so that we can observe that.
And I think, and, and in that respect,
I don't think the right and conservatives have
really changed our policies or I don't think we've gotten more extreme.
I think the left has gotten vastly more extreme.
They've changed their policies radically. Uh, Medicare for all open borders.
I mean effectively open borders, they don't like to use the word,
but when you're saying decriminalize it,
when you're saying no infrastructure at all on the border,
when you're saying no more ice detention beds, you're,
you're effectively saying open borders cause you don't want to enforce it and
you don't want to stop it. So I don't, I don't know what else to call it. Um,
you know, and those are just some example. The green new deal. I mean,
socialism's a good word now. So like I think there's,
I think that on that loan that measure, uh,
only one side has really moved to an extreme as far as policy policy positions
go. And to your point, you look at Barack Obama and he's, he's not the only one.
You can look at Chuck Schumer's old comments on this stuff. I mean it's you,
you Trump could have written those statements for them. Yeah. And um,
what can change done? The real issue is not people coming over here, uh,
seeking work, good people that just want to do better for their life.
The real issue was drugs and crime.
What can be done to mitigate the effect of the Mexican drug cartels?
Cause that seems to be our biggest worry.
Our biggest worry is that cartels and cartel violence. [inaudible] well, no, I,
well our biggest worry, that is a worry but, but there's a, again,
to go back to a matter of sustainability and sovereignty in terms of the amount
of people that, yeah, I don't, I don't, I never, I actually never,
when I talk about the immigration issue,
actually never talk about the drugs and the crime because I don't want to label
these good people as criminals, drug dealers, you know that that's the wrong,
that's the wrong in most investment you are.
But that just because you're a good person and you want nice things doesn't mean
you get to move to the front of the line. I don't remember immigration policy.
So a important point to note for people that don't know,
it's kind of a shocking statistic.
We let in more legal immigrants in any other country. Yeah, yeah.
Over a million a year. Um, I think become citizens and much more than that.
Granted visas. So, and there's a,
there's a perfectly reasonable debate to have about how many work visa should we
have. Should we increase it or should we decrease it?
But now how does someone get over here and how do we know that they don't have a
history of violent crime? Sure. Like, and I, you know,
I advocate for a merit based system with the president proposed I think is
absolutely right. We, we,
we have the opportunity to choose the best people from the world to come here.
And if you're a refugee, we have a system for that.
And if you're in an actual asylum seeker, we have a system for that.
But what we should be a totally opposed to is this idea that just because you
made it to walk across the border,
that all of a sudden you get to cut to the front of the line.
And that's exactly what's happening right now. Um,
because of the loopholes we have, if you bring a child with you,
our laws are written so that we basically can't enforce it.
We cannot enforce these laws. Um, and this is for a couple of reasons. One,
the Flores settlement you hear have heard that a lot.
What it means is you can't attain a child past 20 days.
So if a family comes across or it's usually it's usually just a part of a family
cause what they actually do is they split up,
they split their own families up because they don't want to deport one of the
parents. Does that make sense? Okay. So the Flores settlement says you have to,
you can't detain children,
which effectively means we can never adjudicate these claims in time.
Whether it's an illegal crossing issue,
like a criminal act of 1329 U S code 1325 illegal crossing or just they're
claiming asylum. Either one. We can't, we can't adjudicate it in time.
So what ends up happening is a catch and release. They say, okay,
show up for court date.
Then what incentive do they have to show up for that court date? You know,
and they just don't. So, and we're talking, you know, Jesus,
in the earlier part of this year we had over a hundred thousand a month.
So it gets to a question of sustainability. Let's say all,
let's say all 100,000 people are perfectly good people, but it's sustainable.
It's a sustainability question. And it's also a fairness question.
Like why do they get to cut in front of the illegal immigrants?
Why do they get so much more priority over all of the other people who want to
be in our country around the world? I mean,
they don't have that opportunity just walk across the border. So it's just,
it's just completely, it's utterly unsustainable.
And if we value a sense of sovereignty and rule of law,
but I think we should and we value the idea of having a managed system,
then we have to put a stop to that and then have a good conversation about,
well, maybe we need more workers. Okay, well then let's increase worker visas.
If that's true. Well,
I think we show sympathy about on them because they're poor people that are
trying to do better for their life.
Whereas we look at people that are coming over from Canada and if we had 100,000
people from Canada illegally immigrating into our country every year,
we would go, Hey Fox, get back over where you are. Like,
do you guys have a great country already?
You don't have the problem of a lack of opportunity in Canada,
the way people do in Mexico.
There's a giant disparity between North America in terms of like a United States
of America and Mexico. The economic possibilities, the the sheriff,
the drug violence law, our laws,
our laws have to be written blind to those subjective terminology. Sure.
You know, and that's, that's really important because otherwise why have them,
like why, why even have a system at all? If you just,
if it's enforced based on feelings,
the best case scenario would be Mexico becomes like Canada, right?
Wouldn't that be the best case scenario? Mexico.
Mexicans are not the one ones that are actually, we're having an issue.
You know, it's, it's vastly central Americans. So again,
this stems from loopholes in our laws. OK. So, uh,
cause I'm Mexican too because they're actually border us, right?
Our laws work where we can actually just put them right back. For the most part,
a single adults to weaken our system works okay with that.
The problem is if you bring a child, and so every,
so everybody tends to bring a child in.
What this also causes is human trafficking.
A lot of these children don't belong to these parents. Okay.
So now we have to look at DNA testing to try and to try and forth this.
And that is what's happening now.
And we find that good amount of kids don't belong to these parents.
So they bring over a kid in order for them to stay.
And what will happen is they'll recycle that kid.
So border patrol often sees the same kid coming through with different adults in
and out and it's, it's terrible. And what other kinds, I mean,
if it's not Mexico, what are the,
the main countries where these people calling in Guatemala, Honduras,
El Salvador. And again,
it seems like the only way that anyone could really truly fix that is if those
countries could rise up to the level of Canada so they could be commensurate
with the United States. And this is what the left says we need to do.
And I don't disagree with it at all. Uh,
the problem with what the left is suggesting is that's the only thing we need to
do. And that's just not true. We also have to enforce our actual laws, but that,
but it's, but it is a bipartisan, I think, agreement that we,
we want to develop the countries closest to us. Uh,
I'm on a call MCO sponsoring a bill that touches does just that.
It's a bipartisan bill. Um,
and I think it encourages a more creative look at development in the central
America. Uh,
the Bush Institute is talks about this a lot and I think it's a really good
idea, which is basically economic empowerment through,
through digital infrastructure. So here in America, I mean,
we made a lot of money just based on the gig economy and every individual can
empower themselves and work towards that. And it's really cool. Uh,
they don't have that opportunity down there.
And it's a lack of digital infrastructure, whether it's broadband or whatever.
Um, so working towards investing in the right things as opposed to just, Hey,
here's some aid that, that your,
your corrupt politicians can line their pockets with.
And we can feel good about ourselves and Pat ourselves on the back and think
like, we're doing good for other countries, but we're really not, again,
feel good or do good. That's always a good question to ask. And so I think,
I think we're, I think we're working towards this solutions in Congress now.
Dan, we've got gotta get you on your flight, so I'm going to let you go.
So it's already three 20 here. That's sad. That's sad. But other than fun,
it was a great conversation. I really appreciate it.
And thank you very much for your time and thank you, Dan Crenshaw.
Ladies and gentlemen. Goodbye.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].